Whoever thought ice tea,
whoever thought ist would wind up being
a dude in a reality show with a white
chick with a big ass. Who would have
thought it would come down to that.
And when you're a kid of original gangster
and that reality show it some pretty
white lady with a big ass ice cube wall.
So yeah,
he's like yelling at his kids guy now
that's his, y'all keep it down back there.
That's the new ice cube.
Y'All keep it down. Damn.
But scrunchy face y'all keep it down.
Damn.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and then you
enter in my last name,
they give you money or less,
you have to pay less money to get
your freak on. They give you 15% off.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah,
it really is a great product.
Very solid product that's like legit.
Like it's 100% you're going to masturbate.
It's a hundred times
better than your hands.
It's,
you know,
it's one of those things where people
would give a shit about it and they have
from the beginning, and you know,
we don't have to name names,
but certain people might have a vested
interest in my professional career.
I know they think, well, Joe Rogan,
I just don't think that's the
right thing to do. Joe Rogan,
that just seems like a fucking disgusting
thing to be endorsing. And I say,
how dare you?
How dare you take me a person who
has basically staked my whole fucking
existence on telling the
truth about everything,
no matter how uncomfortable it is.
And you want me to shut down
the rubber pussy business? Well,
I guess why the rubber pussy is
way better than fucking your hand.
It's just better. Guess
what? The rubber plus,
he's probably better than a lot
of girls you've had sex with.
And that's not a joke. It's like
the best vagina ever. And it's fake.
Of course. It's not attached to a
human. It's not as good as having sex.
It's not like I'm asking you to
be d human or anything like that,
but I'm just saying if you're going to
beat off and you're going to beat off,
it's like a dessert. It's like vacation,
like treat yourself once in a while.
Like a general,
like a gentleman.
The only problem is you will
shoot like a real sexual load lot,
not like a jerking off load
and you shoot like a sex load,
so it puts you away like you,
you'll, you'll fall asleep.
You do have the possibility of waking
up with someone's screaming at you while
you've got the fleshlight still
on your dick and your alcohol,
your pants don't wear your ankles.
I never thought about that job because
you really do when you're fucking the
extra pulsing of your Dick. You know
when I get a little extra pumping,
the next up,
your body's convinced it's a real vagina.
Totally. You should way bigger loads and
it's way at the end of it, you're like,
you're really crash,
so you could do have more of a possibility
of getting busted if you pass out
idiot. Especially if you do it in your
office or something. Here's a tip.
Also if you, if you're going to
wash it off in your bathroom,
I usually keep it right on my sink while
it's still, you know, drying and stuff.
Don't use your hair clippers anywhere
near it because I got a bunch of hair all
over it and it's impossible to get
like hair pieces off your flashlight.
So now mine looks like I had
like a five o'clock shadow.
It's creepy dude. It's
really gross. It's like the,
like late eighties when they first
started shaving, you know, we will,
I did Dave's old porn,
you know the David tell a thing,
which David tells sits you and you and him
a watch a porn films. And it's
really funny because first of all,
Dave could watch cartoon, he could
watch anything. And it's funny,
he's just hilarious,
but they're all bushy man.
This fucking Harry boxes.
It's really crazy. I like
it. Do you like that? I like,
I tell you what, it doesn't bother me. It
doesn't, it doesn't make me sad. You know,
I don't go, oh, wouldn't fuck her over.
Got Crazy box. I'd be like, your hair,
you dirty little bitch. They're still
hot. It doesn't make them less hot.
It's a weird aesthetic
choice that we have. We,
we've turned and essentially all
women have had to gone it go into it.
It's the porno look period. There's
no, no bushes anymore. Bushes are gone.
When was the last time he even saw
pubic hair? You see like little Tufts,
like a whisper of a pubic hair.
No one has a real Bush anymore,
but they're out there.
They just hide them.
He's fucking ugly as sin. Also that bald
motherfucking monkey at the end of it,
before you stick your Dick in it while
you're looking at you like, damn,
this thing looks like,
and then you have all these images.
You even giggle at times during sex.
You look at that fucking
monkey with that hair.
It has a little personality to it.
Whether it's a launch pad,
whether it's got that Julius
Erving, fucking look. I liked it.
You get a little sweat man. It gives
that little monkey at different Patois.
You know what I'm saying?
Especially like she used to silliness.
Something smells like olive oil or
something because of that and the other
reason why women had big bushes because
they depended more conditioner women
until they want to fucking make a move.
You know what I'm saying?
They dye their hair that blonde streak
and they were out of the fucking house.
They don't use conditioner.
Who has conditioner? That hat?
That's what girls do. Well, a
Balsam. That was an old school.
You don't think girls have that shit.
You put conditioner on,
you wash it off and the
condition didn't even come up.
Well the conditioners like
a billion dollar market man,
there's a lot of chicks out there use it
conditioner like a big fucking,
we're also brought to you by on it.com
makers is Alpha brain. That's on it.
O. N. N. I. T. R. Hemp protein
should be out any day now as a as,
as the kettlebells,
kettlebells are very difficult
to get the distribution in order.
As you can imagine, we're sending cannon
balls to you. I mean we're sending,
we're sending you 70 pound
fucking cannon balls and bigger.
Some of them are even bigger than 70
pounds. They're ridiculous. And, uh,
the other crazy kettlebells that I'll
tell you about that in the future.
So the hemp protein is coming
to all that coming up very soon.
Alpha brain is the number one product.
The biggest one that I use that comes
out on a.com is the one that I literally,
if I go on the road and I don't have it
with me, I go, fuck, I get angry on it.
Curious actually about the Alpha
brain. Yeah, I took it today.
I've got to get you some of it.
I'll get you some of it so you could
try it for yourself and tell me what you
think. You'd have a pretty extensive
experience in supplements. So I would,
uh, I would say you'd be
a good guy to give it to.
Have you ever fucked around
with nootropics? Do you?
Little bit. A little bit, yeah.
Do you ever try a Roman ASCII stuff? And
not yet. Actually, I have it saved, uh,
from listening to you guys and
you talk about his is really good.
His has a little bit of caffeine too. If
so, if you're into, if you want to be,
I believe it does.
I want them to speak it speak,
but it's called neuro run and I recommend
that as well. There's a all by the way,
the ingredients Alpha brain, if you know,
if you're like, oh, it's too expensive,
but Bubba, look, steal the
ingredients. It's real simple.
You can see them on the bottles,
it's listed online. Go there,
find out what it is buying in bulk and
save yourself some money. I swear to God,
if you're happy and
you're, you know, you're,
you're feeling good from
all this stuff and you're,
you're experiencing a
benefit from nootropics.
I don't even care when we're
much more concern. Hmm.
I just took them right there.
We're much more concerned with
people not feeling ripped off.
This is also why we have a 100% money
back guarantee on the first order of 30
pills that you buy. When you
buy it. You try it out, you go,
I don't feel like that was worth it. You
don't even have to send it back. Just,
you just tell us and
you get your money back.
We are trying as hard as humanly possible
to not rip anybody off and to sell
something that I believe in.
And then I've been using for a long time.
I'm a big advocate of nutrition.
I'm a big advocate of vitamins and
supplements and eating healthy foods and a
lot of fresh vegetables and get your
fido nutrients in and, and you know,
a healthy bacteria in
your body like probiotics.
I'm a big fan of acidophilus and I'm
a big fan of nootropics and if you're,
if you're interested in any of this stuff,
please Google it. It's n o, t, r, O, p.
I. C, that's the word.
Nootropic a lot of controversy
on it at one both ways. You know,
both sides of interesting arguments
for me. I've had excellent results. Uh,
I believe in him 100% and uh,
that's why I endorse on it and that's
why on it is a sponsor of the podcast.
There's a bunch of different
other supplements on it.
One of them's called shroom tech sport.
There's going to be a big two page
article about that and fighters only.
I'm excited about that. They just
sent it to me. They have a day. Um,
people fucking love it.
It's one of the best supplements I have
ever used as far as like endurance as
far as like giving you energy while
you work out. It's got a quarter steps,
mushrooms in it and a ton of 12 and
a lot of other shit. And like I said,
if you can find the ingredients, go steal
it, steal the ingredients, make a sh,
make your own shit, dude. Save some money.
But if you don't want to save any money,
go to [inaudible] dot com you want to
save 10% use a code name Brogan and you
get a 10% off. Well orders. Yeah. If
you'd like. I don't give a fuck Yo,
I'm that kind of baller. There's some
people that just won't cut coupons,
you know what I'm saying?
All right. That's it folks.
Mike Dolce is here and we're going
to get to the bottom of shit.
The food you eat,
motherfuckers. Oh, experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
[inaudible] also joining us.
Of course,
yours
is the one and only mad
flavor, Aka Joey, Coco Diaz.
And I have here something that everybody
has to try. It's Grillo's pickles,
[inaudible] pickles from Boston.
They send them to me in the mail.
This is the best fucking pickles known,
known to human things,
known to human beings.
They're fresh and they make them
and they send them from Boston.
And this is the spicy ones.
It's Grillo's pickles.
You've got try one of these
motherfuckers. Dude, this shit's legit.
Mike Dolce knows about food.
Mike Dolce is,
you are a nutritional
consultant to all these, uh,
various MMA fighters and
probably the most famous one. No,
I'm certainly the most
famous one by a long shot.
I can't think of anybody who has,
uh,
gotten so many different fighters,
uh, on track as far as nutrition,
as far as, uh, you know,
getting their weight in order.
So many guys like Tiago Alvarez who had
always had problems getting on. Wait,
once you started working with
you, no problems. You know what,
what got you into this?
I mean you do you have a
background in nutrition from
college? LikeW , w how many,
you know so much about it. Just
from reading books, from experience,
life experience, education,
you know, of course.
I've been focused on this my
whole life since I was a kid,
since I was in single digits actually,
which I think Joey might reference. Um,
since you were a little kid,
you're just like nutrition.
Nice room, Camrys, pickles.
Good. How could these fucking pit bulls
give me some of the pickles? Kill you?
Fucked up. You got to have something
to go with them. Like a tofu steak
or something delicious.
I didn't bring you something to go
in it and that's where you upset.
You have in front of Mike Dalton.
You're talking about the ink priest.
Romie what are you going to do it for?
Streets mashing on this pickle though.
It's pretty good as fuck. You know what?
You gave the wrong credit. You said,
you know,
how do you get from nutrition number
one of these for motherfucking Belmont,
New Jersey. That's right. If you don't
know about food and you're from Belmont,
you should shoot yourself. That's what
I'm saying. You know what I'm saying?
Nobody gives you a ranch
dressing and Belmont dropped
her for me. Dressing. Yeah.
I was still on the ranch.
Yessing bad for you.
Why do you serve it with French fries?
Some people like white people like it
that's not allowed on the east coast.
I don't mind it. Yeah, it's a, it's a,
it's a white people thing. White people.
Some people, well people with, I dunno,
people did a little duller tones to them,
you know,
tell her personality was like, oh it's
almost nothing. And someone was like,
you just eat and rough fat.
I'm were creeped out by
people like thousand island.
I think that's more
creepy. Yeah, that's nasty.
That's something you like when you're
a little kid cause you think you're
getting away with something because
it tastes almost sweet. It's like, oh,
like ketchup, like catch up
as like a dessert, you know?
I really is. It's fucking,
it's a fruit. Tomatoes or fruit. There's
a lot of people don't even realize that.
That's why everybody likes ketchup.
Ketchup is all sugar.
You're getting sugary sweet,
some weird fucking vegetables.
It's been mashed up and they stick
your French fries into no delicious.
It's fucking good, but probably
not so good for you. Right?
Ketchup is actually depending, you
know, get it from organic sources. Uh,
make sure you limit the processing. Most
important, anything is good for you.
If you take out the processing and the
processing is needed to preserve these
things sometimes or the processing is
needed to turn a batch of chemicals into a
food substitute that actually tastes
like something from the earth. Whoa.
Would be processing.
Does that scare you when you see shit
like that going down? It scares
the hell out of me, man. It, it,
it gets me out of bed every day. It
keeps me like, that's all I see in.
It's all I focus on. What do you think
about all this genetically modified foods?
Are you ended that at all?
Do you understand as much
about that? That's uh, that's,
that's the end of the planet.
That's the end of the earth,
I think is, uh, the, the,
the modification, the alteration
of, of our DNA of the human race,
let's say through new new food sources,
unrecognized maybe on,
on a simulated and, uh, um,
further reactions happen within the human
body that we may or may not understand
yet because of that.
Yeah.
We don't even know what the fuck that
genetically modified crops are doing to
people, right? Yeah.
But they're there in abundance and
they're inexpensive and they taste good.
So yeah. And they're poisoning other
crops. They're infiltrating their,
there's their seeds or whatever the
fuck it is, gets in the air and uh,
gets to other people's land somehow
or another. And these people,
they get cross pollinated.
And so they started growing
these genetically modified crops,
not unbeknownst to them. And then they
get sued by Monsanto, which is incredible.
The crazy thing about those Monsanto
things is you can't even get seeds from
them. You know, like you buy the corn,
it's like the way it used
to be is you would buy corn,
you get the seeds from that corn
itself planted and make new corn.
Like that's how plants work.
Yeah. Monsanto, they don't,
they don't roll like that.
They don't roll like that.
You ain't getting no seeds
bitch. You don't get seeds,
you don't get seeds. They don't
make seeds. They're there.
Their food makes their seeds make
food and then you don't own it.
Next year you own it. This year
you, you buy the seeds for the year.
So if you have like some, you know, some,
some plants and you think you're going
to like just go old school American
Indian style and just,
we'll take the seeds from them and we'll
harvest and we'll, we'll, you know,
create a, a, a beautiful,
sustainable environment. No, no,
no. You buy this every year. Yeah. You,
we got your bitch at our price and
there's so many dudes that are click
committing suicide in third
world countries that had
been roped into doing this
shit with Monsanto. I think they have a
huge problem in India. I believe it was,
there's a lot of suicidal,
let me, I should look that up,
but I'm pretty sure that's what it is.
Suicides from there,
they're depressed that they get
stuck in with these loans. Yeah.
Thousands of farmers are
committing suicide. Yeah. Yeah.
This is crazy, man. But what,
what's what's happening
is they essentially go in
economic hitman style and a
offer these people seeds and you know,
and sort of take over the
situation and make sure that, uh,
these people are using their stuff. And
then the farmers, uh, they get stuck,
uh, like going fuck loads of
money and they can't pay it.
So is it illegal for them to own
other seats? I don't know. You know,
I'd have to find out. I
mean, if that's the case,
they got really fucked
over by their country,
but I'm reading an article
about it right now. If you,
you just, just Google, um, uh,
what did I Google?
Just Google India.
Monsanto suicide.
And there's a bunch of different,
don't say the Brian. That's
stupid. That was the only funny,
the first 3000 times
you said it. Um, yeah.
Fuck man. It's really, it's really scary.
But there's all sorts of different crops
and seeds that a Monsanto apparently.
Yeah, track. Wow. There's
thousands of fucking suicides.
This is really scary shit.
They're saying that it's at least
200,000 suicides in India connected to
Monsanto.
Wrap your head around that shit.
200,000 people have committed suicide
because Monsanto's got them into
the seed game. This game pitch, I'll,
you mean my fees? Oh, you got
a baby that's crying. Oh Man.
Mass scenes. Juan Santos just
got, this is just running shit.
That's really pretty scary. How big of a
company are they? Oh, they're enormous.
There's so enormous that they, it was, uh,
the black water was sold to someone
and they don't know who it was.
And one of the people in
the running was Monsanto.
They believe that Monsanto was interested
in black water. If that's the case,
that means like the biggest food company
in the world has the biggest mercenary
group under the world working for them.
Gangster. That's his gangster. She gets,
that's his gangster. As you
get, they, they hired some
marks. They're like, you know,
we're just taking over the world by
selling them fucking shitty seeds,
the taking over the world and they've
got their own army, by the way.
And not just any army got the
best one of the world. Wow.
It's a will you live in a crazy world,
man. We live in a movie. We really do.
We live in some crazy gangster movie.
Absolutely. So back to the food,
you, um, you'd, you'd get these
fighters. And so what do you do?
Basically you write out all of their
nutrition, everything they can eat,
what time they eat it, blah, blah,
blah. Like how do you, what do you do?
No, um, it, it depends on the athlete.
Number one, it depends on the person,
what their goal is.
So the first thing I do is I fly out
there in a shadow him for a few days,
hang out with the Friday, Saturday,
Sunday, hang out with them,
hanging out with their families, stay
in the guest room, whatever. And uh,
I just laid back and I watch and I see,
and then we start to talk and
build a relationship. And A,
I start to fill in the cracks.
I troubleshoot, eat bad
instead of this, you know,
you got training at 11,
you wake up 10 45
daddy, do you have to be, does that,
does that fall into play or I wouldn't
say dad, let me, let me say how much of a,
um, uh, how much of an older
brother, how much of a,
how much of a situation
where, you know, these guys,
like they're looking for
someone to help them to coach
coaches. The most respectful way of
putting it mean how many, I know a lot.
It's amazing how many fighters need
like someone to tell them what to do.
Like there's a lot of guys
who were super independent,
but there's a lot of guys who
aren't that independent at all.
And then they essentially need someone
to tell him what to do and in order for
them to shut that aspect aspect
of their brain off and be
successful. Yeah, it's, uh, I,
I do as is a coach. You know,
I'm a full time coach and the
coaching in certain areas, the guys,
some guys I actually do develop
that brother type of bond with,
but it's not every guy, you
know, because professional,
I worked with a bunch of guys and you
only have so much emotional output or,
or can we not naming any names?
Like what's the most difficult situation
that you'd have to encounter? Um,
it's the people around
the athlete, you know, in,
in a coach relationship one
on one. It's like a, you know,
you're working with your Moitai coach,
you're in the room, nobody's there.
You hear everything, you do, everything,
you respond to everything and the
more people in that room are talking,
the less you're going to retain the
technique can execute the technique.
Same thing with the things
that I do. Yeah. That's just
like performing on stage.
If you're performing on stage,
someone's talking in the background,
that Shit's annoying. If you're training
and use a bunch of people in the room,
people don't realize that like training,
especially training the fight that's like,
that requires all of your
fucking attention. Sure.
Everybody treats it like it's no big deal.
Like you're out there.
Just even if you were playing pool,
if he were lined up on a difficult shot
and a bunch of people were talking,
he'd be like, well, you shut the fuck up
and nobody's punching you in the face,
kick you in the face in front of millions
of people in your mortgage is on the
line when you're playing pool and
they've got a bunch of yes men.
So that's what it is. Yeah. Well I mean
everybody has, we all have yes men,
right in our own way. And, and it's,
it's the motivation or it's what's best
for the athlete at that given time.
You know, some athletes need some,
yes, men are random just to keep their,
their confidence up and keep
their lifestyle secure. Um,
but it's the people that are kind of
pushing in the wrong areas at that given
point, you know, eight weeks before
applied, six, four, two, you know,
the closer you get the, uh,
the less room for inefficiency.
I think you have. So you Kinda, you know,
I think I helped with
some guys eliminate that.
And sometimes it's through nutrition,
sometimes it's through training too much,
too little, you know, sleep
patterns, just perception.
And sometimes it's a, it's other aspects
of the team, maybe not it's external,
it's internal, you know, the,
the striking coach or the
wrestling coach or you know,
one coach wants to do too much or
all the coaches want to do too much.
So being that I'm with
the athlete more often,
I can see what their
recuperation level is,
how they're performing daily.
Um,
and kind of moderate via the peaking let's
there the intensity and the volume of
the overall training session.
So when you go to these different camps,
do you see like a constant paradigm like
replaying itself over and over again or
one guy is trying to get in control of
the camp and all the other guys trying to
push that guy out.
Do you see like a lot of that,
a psychological bullshit that
goes on behind the scenes? Yeah,
but I don't think it's any
different in a fight camp than it.
Isn't that a family or an office
environment or the PTA, you know,
that's probably worse with
it. It's everywhere. And
there's some, you know, a lot.
I'm, I'm blessed that a lot
of the teams that I work with,
I'm fortunate enough to work with.
There's none of that.
We all respect each other as
professionals and the athletes, the boss,
I call it the Microsoft structure,
the athlete is Bill Gates and I'm the
best damn keyboard builder in the world.
And that's what I do.
And that's all I want to do.
I can certainly help the guy that built
the monitor and the office next to me,
but you know,
I,
I'm the best keyboard guy
and we'll communicate around
the board and we'll give
everything to the man on top.
He makes the decisions.
I don't think people realize
the importance for a fighter
of having a strong and
professional team, having people
that are not bullshit artists,
they're not charlatans,
they're not egomaniacs.
They know what the fuck they're doing.
They're professionals.
That's what they're there for. And
everybody has a job. Being a nutritionist,
be it a strength and conditioning coach.
Everyone is the real fucking deal.
That's a real jujitsu coach. This is a
real Moy Thai coach. And, and you know,
one of the things that's driving me crazy
is all these fighters that are getting
injured,
like Dominick Cruz got injured because
they're all training together all in one
room.
Dominick Cruz is preparing to defend
his fucking Bantam weight world title.
And his knee gets blown out because
someone lands on him. That's fucked up.
You're talking about someone
he's not training with.
If people don't understand this,
he's training with one person there.
They're sparring and next to him,
two other dudes are working out and they
collide into the champ. First of all,
those dudes are idiots.
There's dudes.
Whoever the fuck was driving
that takedown was an idiot.
Whoever the fuck was defending
it was an idiot. Those guys are,
they're right next to a guy
who's preparing to fucking
train for his world title.
I shouldn't say they're idiots and say, I
should say I've done it. The same thing.
It's an idiotic move. She should be
way the fuck away from that guy. Yeah.
That shit happened to Rashad.
It happened to, you know,
it's happened to a couple
guys. Like that's some Bush
league shit. Yeah. Small. Uh,
small mistake and a huge, huge
price to pay. Right? Yeah.
I shouldn't have said that guys
who are training or an idiot's.
What I should say is it's an
idiotic way to set up a room.
It's an idiotic way to set up a training
room when the guy's training for the
fucking world title in a period. It's
crazy. Bush league, like I hear it.
It drives me nuts was you are, when
you come to a camp, how do you,
uh, you, you're obviously
brought in for nutrition,
but if you see like some other bullshit,
some things that you need to deal with,
some things that, you know, like
you'd say it to the athlete, like,
here's your problem.
You have this big social drama going on
and you've got to pick a side and stick
with that and then get,
be done with this because otherwise you're
dealing with this fucking social shit
and you're,
you're,
that's taking up resources that you could
be using to train and concentrate and
your opponent. Absolutely.
So you, you breathe. Do you,
are you the guy who goes to the athlete?
You got everybody. I go to the athlete,
I go to the, the, the person involved,
you know,
and we speak about
professionals, you know,
it's not emotional,
it's professional and you have the luxury
of really being so requested that uh,
it's, it's, you know,
you don't have to worry about like this
one guy who is going to fire you because
you know, you upset his friend
and you know, as you know,
as buck got hurt now I think
the people that I work with, um,
they called drift for a fucking reason.
They brought me there for a reason.
There's something not right. You
know, we don't know if it's nutrition,
whatever they called you in for we, have
you ever been a situation where a fly,
it has got like a crazy fucking old lady.
Absolutely. Every fight. I had a crazy,
oh my God. And Go, come in
for a second dog. This chick,
she got to go right there.
That's a fucking, yeah.
May I have heard some things. There
was so shy from dudes who were like the
baddest motherfuckers you would think this
dude ain't taking no shit from nobody.
And you know,
night before his fight,
his girlfriend wants to fucking
fight all night, won't let him sleep.
It keeps waking him up
and fucking with him,
calling him a loser and leaves
the middle of the night.
It doesn't say where he's going
and he can't go back to sleep.
He's calling her phone.
She won't answer there in Vegas.
This bitch just went out at 5:00 AM,
you know,
and these guys have to fight the next
day and deal with it because a lot of,
to become a professional athlete,
to become a guy,
especially who wants to be a cage
fighter, you know, a lot of these people,
or they're the type of impulsive athletes
that attract crazy broads cause crazy
bods, dude, nutty shit.
Like, you know, you know,
they'll suck your Dick like 10 minutes
after meeting you and you're like, Whoa,
this pitch is hot. She is
both, this is nuts. Well, she's
crazy. She's fucking crazy.
And then it ended in crazy impulsiveness
and made her blow you in a bathroom.
That's, that's not what leads to a
good relationship. Like absolute,
that girl's a freak. You know, you
gotta get the fuck away from me.
You're not supposed to have kids
with her. Move her in. Yeah,
with a lot of these guys and move her
in. They have kids with them. These,
those you gotta be careful and not,
I'm not saying don't do it,
but I'm saying be careful.
You gotta be careful of that all in
relationship will you meet somebody and
right away the girls all in and the
guys all in and the two of you are like,
I love you. I love you. Spend 15 hours
a day with each other every day. That
guy, that's your manager. I don't like how
he talks to you. Yes. Bye Greg Jackson.
I don't like him. I don't like his
eyes. I don't trust them. Oh yeah,
they always put my father in law. I think
my father should train. He's getting up
separate. Separate you from the herd.
It's amazing. You have to go to,
somebody's going to be
straight up. There's no fucking
beating around the bush.
Listen, I've seen the
behavior, first of all,
what you're doing at the gym
with a fucking 90 young cause.
This shit that you can't even believe you
walk in and it's not that the fighters
a fucked up, it's that they have little
things that you're tightening up.
We all could have somebody come
into our lives and say, hey dog,
you got to start getting up at seven.
You got to start eating at six 15,
which makes a lot of sense.
One of the things that get booked,
I told Joe about it.
I go,
I can't give fucking used to this
dolce water before fucking coffee shit.
Every time I drink water in the morning,
first off,
I got a cramp in my stomach like
pills or vitamins in the morning.
But it's explaining what
you're talking about.
Why do you have to drink water before?
Tough to jump the metabolism. Uh,
Mike and his book says to drink
coffee after your meal. Uh,
I think the first time I read it was
the water first to get your metabolism
going, which makes sense. It makes
a lot of sense. I don't understand.
How does water get your metabolism going?
What does it do?
So you push the water through your body
and starting to digestive process to
working to start working,
to prepare your diet,
digestive environment for the food
that's next to come. So now you put the,
the nutrients in the body and we
get them metabolism, start to work,
start the process.
And then if you're a coffee drinker
and then you can have some coffee,
which is a cynic, you know, so you
want something already down there.
So it's to not
increase or overload a digestive
system with the acidity, which is hard.
We all know, you know, you have a little
bit of coffee on an empty stomach.
You're jacked up for days.
We're not in the next six hours a room.
You've got to train in two
hours. You grown in, you know,
so you start your day in
the proper, uh, proper note.
Whether you're going in an office, it
doesn't matter. I'll go in the office,
we go into the gym to train. It
doesn't matter. It's the same thing.
What do you think about
coffee for athletes before
they compete? Is that okay?
Absolutely. I'm, I'm
sipping on one right now.
Like a lot of guys jacked themselves up
with caffeine before they fire. Right.
As long as they're used to it.
Um,
nothing that they haven't been
doing in the last three weeks.
All of a sudden guys fight night,
they want to drink a, you know,
an energy drink or this new pill.
Your heart beat too fast.
Can't calm yourself down.
We can't predict what the is going to be.
We haven't tested it.
Tested in the gym. Yeah.
When I was talking to
Chelsea son and he was uh,
talking about how he uses like those
little vibrant type caffeine pills,
which are legal, he knows what
the law, the legal, you know,
doses and that way when
he's taking the pills,
he never has to worry because if
you drink like a 20 ounce Starbucks,
a lot of folks don't know you might
like Piss hot for caffeine. Like you,
you only can have a certain amount.
Yeah.
Caffeine is a PR weird performance
enhancing drug and that it's legal.
You're allowed to drink caffeine,
but you're only allowed to
drink a certain amount of it.
It's really fascinating isn't it?
Yeah. Because uh, if folks don't know,
like if you get, we got our coffee
from lovebirds cafe and bakery.
Very nice place down the street and a
nice mom and pop shop here in Pasadena.
But um, you go to Starbucks and
you get one of them vent these,
that's a lot of God damn cap on.
It's way more caffeine.
Maybe I've been doing Trenton, but I
think that's a lot of ice buddy. No, no,
I do light ice. Trenta iced coffee,
unsweetened every single day. Oh my God.
Is that a strong as a
regular coffee? It's, it's,
it's stronger actually cause they actually
make it stronger because the ice is
supposed to melt it. You're going to
die. So if they just did regular coffee,
so it's actually, yeah, it's stronger.
Well you would not be able to fight
in the UFC for sure. If you did,
you would get Keith Kaiser up your ass.
That would be my excuse for not fighting
in that. You have to do, I just coughing.
Sorry. Isn't it funny that you, you can't
smoke weed but you can smoke cigarettes.
No one, you don't, you don't test hot for
cigarettes. This is hilarious. It live.
They're looking out for you fucking idiot.
You can't smoke legal weed either.
Like Nick Diaz has a goddamn prescription.
And by the way, the prescriptions,
uh, carries over to Nevada is a,
Nevada has medical marijuana
too. So why do they, you know,
why do you have to apply for some
exemption? It's so ridiculous. So silly.
Long as you're not fighting high and
you can take pills, you know, um,
the different medical pills,
psychological pills you can take
during the training in less time.
You closer to the fight, then
you could marijuana. I, yeah.
I don't know how long it
takes to cycle off Adderall,
but I do know that fighters had been
told they can't fight on it. On Adderall.
Xanax. Fight Week. Yeah. How
many days does that wear off?
I don't know the, but the,
the life of it specifically,
but I know guys can be on that flight
weekend and test fine and be legal going
up and up, disclose everything.
It's no problem. I've done Xanax,
but from what I understand,
one of the problems with Xanaxes,
although it alleviates anxiety,
there's sort of a rubber band effect and
after it wears off, you're more anxious.
Then you were even before you took that,
it sticks to you fucking fat.
So if you take 10 milligrams of Valium,
your body only really uses five.
The only five, the other five
go into your body and sit there.
So the next morning when you wake up,
you blow those two hits to
take a right to fucking work.
Those two hits of that fucking number of
strongly what they usually are because
Valium gets sits in your fat and
your body releases it as it needs it.
So it might need it to fall asleep,
but then it holds on to the rest.
That's what I don't like about value.
You have that hangover the next day.
Any of those things are fucking
horrible. Ambien, get her up.
I mean people buying cars, people cook
and fucking meals and going shopping.
How the fuck go shopping if
it gets they go shopping.
Yeah. Well that's what
happens when you do a ambient.
I have a whole bit about it
in my act cause it's true.
A friend of mine did
make a fucking Turkey,
made a Turkey wise on Ambien and I
do a bit about it and my it true,
it doesn't remember going to supermarket.
Totally legal may not fucking dark age.
Yeah. I think all the anxiety medication
in the market is bullshit or shit.
I think if you go to acupuncture and a
meditated would do the same to do all the
same things.
You say that man, but your circumstances
are not everyone else's circumstances.
I would never say that he's, some people
don't need an anti anxiety medication.
Whatever situation they're in.
I wouldn't say it's bullshit. I
did not say that. I said the ones I
was prescribed we'll fucking horrific.
Okay. Horrific. To the point where I gave
him to Sergio, love this motherfucker,
call me the next day and said dog,
whatever it was and that shit is bad.
When Sergio Love Cork and I
told you this other Pi's. Yeah,
you told me you gave me,
gave a medication. Great Guy.
And I was taking these things.
I'm going,
I'm feeling fucked up on these anxiety
pills. I got these from Bob Hope.
This is the sag doctor.
They're not going to give me shit.
So it takes away your anxiety by making
him feel like shit. Oh, I was feeling,
I was feeling depressed. I
was feeling like everything
was very moody. Everything.
When I was on it, I felt like I
was dark. I couldn't do comedy.
Do you mean like that for,
I felt like I was living a fucking
black and white movie. Wow.
That's hard to describe to people.
You feel like you're in a
black and white movie and I,
something wasn't right that was
taken to afternoon naps. You know,
it wasn't right. And I said one day,
wait a second, I got a test monkey.
I got my boy. I call this motherfucker
up cause I've seen, I seen my boy,
10 ten's I've seen them before.
10 zero one shot.
Anybody weeds for tens and at the end of
the night says I 1310s you're a savage.
It takes a missile and
knock that motherfucker,
fellow chocolate dialing going nowhere.
You're going to be pounded
that motherfucker for hours.
1310s are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
You do a little blown of mixed it up
a little bit and milligrams of valley.
What it, what does one do? One fucking
knock you out from here to England. Jesus.
How was he taking?
When you're drinking and you're drinking,
your adrenaline is still
alive. Probably goes into your fat and
that's kind of a big guy. He's a big guy.
But the fucking funny thing was that
when he called me the next day and said
they was fucked up, I was like, I just
flushed him. And I said, that's it.
Even though I have a fear of needles,
I'm going to hit this acupuncture.
Why not let me give it a shot. I
don't understand people who, uh,
need to get happy because I'm happy.
You know what I'm saying?
But I know people that have been unhappy.
I don't understand like the desire to
try to achieve happiness cause right.
I'm a happy person.
I surround myself with happy people.
I do what I want to do for a living.
I got a lot of loved ones. Happiness.
That's happiness to me.
I know people though that just
got stuck in a fucking bad place.
And if they're not bad people,
they just got stuck in a bad place.
And I know that anti anxiety medication
and I know that antidepressants have a
place in this world and the
real problem is corruption.
The real problem is these fucking asshole
doctors that want to prescribe it for
everyone. That doesn't feel good that
day. They want to, I mean they'll,
they'll try to prescribe that shit.
There's,
there's some unscrupulous
motherfuckers they, we know,
they get kickbacks from
pharmaceutical companies.
We know that pharmaceutical
representatives, they, they
take them out to dinners.
And I know this because Mrs Rogan's
mom is a nurse and you know,
I've seen like I've seen how that whole
business works. It's creepy as fuck.
When is a business of the advertise
these fucking things on TV man.
They haven't been magazines. It's crazy.
You're right. Joy. I fucked up cause,
but I also think that people should try
every other avenue before they go on.
But that's for facts.
That's for fucking sure.
From exercise to meditate
and to yoga to the needles.
I don't give a fuck of
the long Bata helps you.
Anything is better than
getting caught into that cycle.
But what I'm trying to say by
my saying that I'm happy is it,
I'm not saying I've always been happy.
I was very dark early in my life.
I was a, when I was, when I was young,
when I was in my early
twenties and my teens, I was a,
I was not a happy person by any stretch
of the imagination and not even remotely,
but I knew it was possible.
And because you,
you,
you manage your life the correct way
because you get to a situation where you
gotta have a lot of good fortune
and you have a lot of good friends.
Your literally, your mental state
becomes a happier mental state.
Like what people don't understand is a
lot of the reason why you feel like shit
is because your life fucking sucks and
you're supposed to feel like shit to
motivate you. They get the
fuck out of the life you're in.
Whether it's a relationship,
whether it's a job,
whatever the situation is that sucks.
Whatever the thing is inside you
that's rotting you out from the inside,
whether it's you want to do something
else but didn't have the balls to pursue
it. You wanted another girl but you
couldn't keep her cause you're a liar.
Whatever the fuck it is that eats at you,
you got to straighten that shit
out or you will never be happy.
You can't just flood yourself
with chemicals that trick
your brain to thinking
that this reality is acceptable because
it's not really what's going on.
What's going on is you
know that you haven't done
the best that you can do. It's about
choices. Yeah. What about the fighter?
That's fine for the championship of the
world on Saturday and two weeks before
he's fighting for the
championship of the world.
He's not sticking her mother's childhood
forever. Fucking stupid reason. You know,
um, something his father said
to him, he wasn't good. Awesome.
Because people have
gotten into funks before.
Big things because your
mind talking about who,
how your mind works in mysterious ways.
Who are you talking about?
Not talking about anybody in particular.
I, I'm sorry, you were talking about a,
was talking about how your mind works.
We both read the art of war,
the war of art.
Know what that guy says.
How a writer will surround
himself with obstacles.
We'll put natural obstacles in front
of ourselves to make us feel, you know,
and your mind,
does it take you to dark places?
It's our own fucking personal resistance.
We know it's good for us and we won't
fucking do it, but it's really weird how,
I can't imagine a fighter,
a comic, you know,
a lot of these comics towards
the end of the Kennison,
a lot of these fighters
towards the and awesome.
I mean the punches in the head
and the mind and insecurities,
they fucking spinning around Bro.
And once you get insecurity in the mix,
you have to go talk to somebody
or it's, it's, it's a ego.
It's all mixed in that same fucking thing.
The ego works too fucking ways, man.
Unquestionably, the ego works two
ways. It's a, it's a dance. You know,
and I think a big part of the dances,
you got to put out an overwhelming
abundance of positive energy.
I think that's the way to avoid all
the funk and all the bad feelings.
You got to put out an overwhelming amount
of positive energy. If you do that,
you have like a surplus out there and then
even the negative shit that comes out,
you just slides right off you.
Cause you've got so much good stuff
coming your way. That's the choices.
The choices make a positive choice.
You make a negative choice in.
The more positive you make,
the more you're surrounded by positive
and in the more positive your situations,
your lifestyle, your, you know, the, the,
the people around you and then the energy.
So now you're like, you, you're a happy
guy because you're, you're positive guy.
You surround yourself with positive
people, you do positive things, you know,
you move forward like that.
You in a,
in a parallel universe could be negative
just because you woke up one day and
you had corn flakes instead of,
you know,
your green smoothie and then you kind of,
we're with a bunch of people and they're
smoking cigarettes in the car and
they're listening to this song that you
don't like and you're stuck in traffic
and your day kind of go shit even more.
And then there's no
coffee at the coffee spot.
You don't have time to get
in there because you're late
for the meeting and your
day keeps spiraling farther and
farther on that negative route.
And then it kind of keeps going that way.
And that's where a lot
of people fall off track.
And I deal with a lot of people
that are unhappy because they're,
they're overweight,
but why are they overweight?
They're overweight because
they're unhappy, so they
emotionally eat or you know,
they, they, they know that
they're not making good decisions,
so they don't feel like
they deserve good things.
So they kind of inflict a
negative situations on himself,
eat bad and smoke cigarette,
hanging out with bad people and
they're kind of caught in that fuck.
But it's easy to get out of that
funk with a decision. You know what?
I'm going to leave.
I'm gonna walk out and go there.
I'm going to drink some water.
I'm going to step out in the sunshine.
I'm going to the gym and then
call my mom just to say hello,
I'm gonna give my wife a kiss
or whatever the heck it is.
You start making those little positive
decisions and boom,
the next thing you know,
you're happy and every day you're more
and more happy and you're successful.
Whether you're a writer or an
entrepreneur or whatever the heck you are.
You know you do dishes,
you love what you do when you're more
successful and everything starts to grow
and explode from there.
You know the fat trains a motherfucker
and you just described it exactly the fat
trains and mother Fucker, because
even if you waved, did at twice.
Even if you wait did it twice at 11 you'll
look, I got to eat again. Cheesecake,
ice cream. It's just your mind works.
You think like that. I have to it again,
just saying that you never fucking
know. You know? You never fucking know.
The fat train is a motherfucker.
It's a psychological train
is what you're trying to say.
It's a fucked up training
that makes you be a junkie.
The same thing that makes me a gambler.
Yeah. The same thing. And it's,
so what we were discussing
before the show started,
you said don't talk was that people in
America don't really fucking know where
to get on that. Get it. Go get off
that train. Yeah. They really don't.
And even if you stop the train and go
get off this scared because they don't
know and there's longevity it staying
off that train for the longest time.
It's not going to happen. Two weeks.
We'll explain what you're saying.
What do you mean by this train? That's
just fat train. It's just a cycle.
It's another word for a cycle of abuse,
of cycle of addiction.
Just sending a behavioral,
one night you'd go on the fucking road
and you go to this comedy club and you're
hungry and you're on the road for a
fucking week straight. And then they,
I don't mean eight weeks fucking
straight and no shit bucking clubs.
You know what I'm talking about?
And you going to eat dinner,
they have French fries and a hamburger
and now you can't sleep because you're
from the fucking east coat.
You're from the west coast,
you're going into the east coast,
you've got the radio pre fucking day.
So lack of sleep puts fucking
weighed on you. And all of a sudden,
next thing you know you'd get,
you're 20 pounds overweight,
you're 30 pounds overweight and you went
on the road and then this happens. I'm,
I'm just, I'm just describing
it how it happened to me.
And you don't know what's going on.
And even though you worked out
all your life and you've walked,
this weight is getting put on and you
know how you can't breathe in your fucking
sleep now you can't
breathe and your sleep.
So I'm scared of fucking needles
and doctors. So you know what?
Maybe if I get a fucking heart attack,
then I'll figure this out.
So on until I get the heart attack,
that's when I'll go in and take
care of this fucking sleep apnea.
It's finally you're not sleeping and
finally you're falling asleep and fucking
lights and your 90 pounds heavier
than when you moved to La.
Even though there's a fucking why MCA
walking distance from your house and you
walked past it and it's
like the devil's house.
You even crossed the fucking street.
You don't even walk in their
fucking state of the city.
That's the factory and the fat train where
people are describing now in America,
obesity was Obama's wife. These
fucking kids are huge. You lost.
You lost a ton of way, Joe.
You asked at one point in time,
which doesn't mean it doesn't matter how
much the job down the fucking street,
35 go down the street right now.
There's not a kid playing
on a fucking street no more.
You mean that all those fucking
houses isn't that one parent.
They can go listen and Monday
I'm going to come out and play.
Stick ball with these fat books while
the computer would have knapsack would
compete with the fuck are these kids gone?
They walk around with 80 pounds on
their fucking bag and then 90 pounds
overweight. But me, it started as an
adult. It didn't start as a six year old.
Fucking kid didn't start as
a six year old fucking kid.
It started when I was 30 and I was already
10 years in the fucking bag of blow
and drinking. You know you don't realize
and I'm one night at the comedy store,
the Fucker, I don't like alcohol. I
don't like the fucking taste of it.
If I'm doing blow out drink sperm,
but if
I don't like the taste,
the apple,
it's a gel soldiers timing ever social
fucking thing I had when I see Joe
drinking a beer, you don't think I
want to grab him. You Mike, don't you?
I do the worst thing in the world.
I get so bored.
I'm so embarrassed and been a mud to that.
All I do is smoke pot like a 13 year old.
That's sometime [inaudible] give me a
fucking cigarette cause I got to feel like
I'm doing something.
You know what the fucking bartender
told me once at the comedy store that I
drank 16 soldiers while I
was there one night. Wow.
You don't 16 soldiers Dooney fucking
your weights. A lot of sugar.
That's a lot of sugar. I was doing that
eight times a day. People don't know that.
A fucking can of soda.
It's six weight watcher points and the
whole day is dirty fucking eight points.
So if you have six cans of Soda, so
what are you going to do about it? No,
it's what you can do to
get off this fucking train.
It's so what do you do about it, bro?
I started with changing my character.
It didn't start with the Diet first.
It started with the fucking character,
which is getting up in the morning
and walking, like you said,
to the mailbox and touching
it and walking back.
Bob Zany used to take
a bus from Hollywood,
the fucking west side of La
or walked back that you know,
little why did he do that?
To lose weight.
People do fucking put themselves
in predicaments. Awesome. You know,
I went to swim. It was a better
option. No, I notice it, but you know,
I want to lose weight. I was
scared. I didn't know how to start.
I asked a bunch of guys,
I knew if I went to Eddie and
sadly I want to lose weight,
he would have thrown me into the fucking
spectrum with digital and I would have
broke my fucking back cause I was four
15 and I told you the first time I got on
a fucking treadmill I going to do two
minutes. Yeah. The little guy said,
well you were four 15 at one time,
the longest shot cheese
that November 415 pounds,
three packs of cigarettes and fucking day.
So before you lose weight or you can go
in any direction you don't like did I
joined karate with black dudes in the
hood so they didn't know who the fuck I
was. It didn't matter who the
fuck I was because I wasn't good.
Where are you going? How are you going
downtown with these two black dudes?
And it's funny because I wanted to,
I wanted to put my mind back to where it
was when I was 13 when I hated fucking
all the stupidity when my mother
used to even say, let me Sunday,
you're going to need a drink cause
you've got to stick up your ass.
But I was fine at that point in my life.
So I took myself and my mind back to that.
I wanted to fucking roll my gear
up in a fucking thing and go back.
And just to take my mind too,
when I was an evil fucking 13 year old,
where if you came up to me with
a cigarette, I'd smack you.
If you came up to me to a joint,
I fucking tackle you.
And if you came up to me with alcohol,
I called you a loser
because my mother had a bar.
So I would watch these
people in the bar and go,
I can't believe my mother makes money off.
These fucking Mumbo was drinking.
They can stay at home for a six pack and
drop $2 or whatever Schlitz was. Yeah.
So before I got my weight loss program
back, I wanted to get my character back.
Even today book, I go to the
fucking gym, like I was telling you,
and I'll do 45 on the bike. I hit the
bag, throw sidekicks, I'm drenched.
People look at me. Everybody's in the
fucking air conditioning. I'm outside.
I go to the YMCAS. I'd go to the one
I could go to any sucking gym and La.
I go to YMCAs because I want to be rugged.
It takes us back to being a fat mother
fucker and enough with this obesity and
all these diseases were a bunch of fat
fucks and that's how to get off the thing.
And I do your little treadmill
workout for beginners,
which I looked at for a month and
go, I'm in no danger. What is this?
What is the treadmill?
I love this fucking treadmill workout
from the beginning of the intermediate.
Joey fucking,
I'm sorry,
what's a treadmill workout?
It's um,
in the book I have a few
different treadmill workouts,
beginner treadmill workout, which
is just an introduction. Um,
what it is broken out.
I can actually pull it up and take a look,
but I have a beginner, an
intermediate, and the advanced,
which is the fight or treadmill workout,
which is basically intervals.
So the fighter,
one minute, eight minutes, one
minute at six minutes, one minute,
eight minutes and it's six minutes per
round. So it's really a six minute round.
I'll never even try that.
The beginner was basically you walk for
five minutes at three miles per hour and
then you put it up to five miles.
Wow. Great. Hear him saying why, why
are you doing it? What is your, um,
for the beginner it's really to get people
active to build that base. You know,
a lot of times,
like Joe was saying,
people that they're out of shape
for whatever reason, you know,
they've been making negative decision.
Now they make a positive decision.
They walk into the gym where
they, you know, have a little
treadmill at the house,
whatever it is.
They start to exercise and they do it
wrong because they follow what they see on
TV. When they fall, what they saw in
the old self magazine or whatever it is,
sore as hell the next day.
They don't perform well,
they look fat, they feel fat,
their clothes are too
tight. Screw this, I'm out.
And that's like Joey saying you walk in
the gym and then you don't go back for a
while that people make the bad decisions.
So what this beginner
treadmill workout is it,
it's getting people on the train wheels,
getting them active,
it's getting their heart moving,
it's getting their blood flowing and
it's a transition into something a little
bit better. Like Joe is a great example.
He started his, you know, hardest.
His hardest pace was
three miles an hour or so.
And then he would go down to one
and he would walk. Now, you know,
a few weeks later he's almost
doubled that or was more than double.
That made tremendous amount of
progress in a short period of time.
Instead of just jumping in and doing,
you know, four miles an hour is your,
your slow. And then six or eight
miles an hour is your fast,
which is what most other people do.
So it's in the book.
I kind of break it down and
make it easy for people.
So you just kind of stared at, you
pressed the buttons and you move forward.
So you just set out a nice roadmap to
follow and this is the best way to achieve
results. And how do you get
people to stick with things?
Do you have particular techniques that
you've developed over the year to,
to motivate guys? Do you you, you give
them inspirational quotes? The like,
yeah, it's a all the above. Really. It's,
it's about accountability. You know,
you have to be accountable. What's
your goal? What's your goal? Joe?
What are you going to do?
You want to, you know,
make this much money or you want to buy
that old house or you want it, you know,
donate x amount of dollars or whatever
the heck it is. What's your goal now?
What are you going do to get there?
Let's
start building steps. Let's
set small goals. Very simple.
And it's basic information that we
all know. I'm not saying anything new,
I'm just maybe holding people accountable
to actually doing it. Well, you know, I,
there's,
there's a term that I use for certain
people and the term is a collector of
ideas and I think that's what you are.
And there's a guy named Jason
Silva is a brilliant guys,
been a real podcast a couple of times.
That is the same thing that he is,
he's a guy who he takes some
of the greatest information
that's available and he
can regurgitate it in a very entertaining
way. Um, there's not wrong with that.
Like you defending that.
Like there's no need to defend that.
That's a legitimate skill as
much as learning, you know,
car mechanics is a skill as much as
learning it, the medical, you know,
science is a skill.
It's all skilled and the ability
to retain all this information. Um,
but you're in a strange
position is the position of, uh,
attempting to motivate people like this.
And you were former fighter as well.
You're on the ultimate fighter. What
season, when you're on season seven,
how many more fights did you have after
that? Um, I had a couple of more handful,
maybe four or five,
you know,
and then just decided to concentrate
on training guys. The training.
That was really the, uh,
the focus in the beginning.
I've always been a coach and I've always
been doing that and I fought because I
loved it and I enjoyed it.
Um,
it helped me be a better coach
and I was pretty good at it. I,
I did decently well. I'll up
until a certain point. Um,
so the enjoyment was there and I was in
the industry. So I know, you know, very,
um,
specifically what the athlete goes there.
Did you find yourself in a situation
when you were thinking about not doing it
anymore and you're wondering
if she's doing any more?
We had like one foot in and
one foot out. Yes. Since, um,
since my first fight in the IFL
first fight in the IFL, um, you know,
I got two pro fights and that two or
three pro fights, first fighting, I fell,
I knocked this kid out. It's the fastest
record in the history that, you know, IFL.
It's, uh, the big who plots on TV
and that when the, you know, it's,
it's team format, the third
victory. So it went from my team.
It's all great stuff when an Xbox live,
which is awesome because
when they just came out,
it was the Xbox and they stepped
up the Xbox live and boom,
I went walking through the airport with
on my shoulder cause I'm not putting
that shit and uh, you know the
baggage. Right, right. I'm caring.
I was trying to buy it for like seven,
$800 in the airport from it. Wow.
It was that new. Yeah, it was awesome.
I didn't know it was such a big dam
and that from that point on I achieved,
that was my goal. You know, pretty modest
goals. I did it. I mean I, you know,
was undefeated even at that point.
And then I just kept rolling forward
a little bit. Still coaching,
very active as a coach.
And at one point I had 40 pro
athletes while I was profiling.
But you weren't concentrating yourself as
much? Um, no, no. Just, it's selfishly,
you know, in a quadrant of my brain I was,
I was going to be the ultimate fighter,
you know, champion and all that stuff. Um,
but that was probably less than 10%
of my true time output, you know,
if you charted what I did in the day
was mostly for everybody else. Yeah.
You can't just be confident and not do
the work. Right. Yeah. Gotta do the work.
It's got to go all in. Treat
it like, especially like
people always say like, hey,
how come you don't have an MMA fight?
Besides the fact that
I'm getting old as fuck.
The real problem is I don't want to do it
and I don't think he should dabble. No,
I'm not going to quit doing comedy.
There's no way I'll quit doing comedy.
There's no way I quit doing this podcast.
There's no, there's no way. I mean,
I'm not going to, and if I didn't quit
comedy, I wouldn't be able to fight.
There's no way, you know, it's just,
I don't think it's something
that you should have asked.
You shouldn't businessman, you shouldn't
have anything else on your mind. I mean,
you could have distractions and
hobbies and all that good stuff,
but when you're training,
you're fucking, that's a,
it's an amazing amount of time
these guys have to devote.
I don't think people realize it.
People like that.
Just watch fights and don't dig
into it and find out what a,
what a training schedule is
like for these fucking kids.
It's incredible psychological impact.
The physical impact is easy.
We can all work hard as human beings,
we can all put our body through that.
It's the psychological impact of knowing
six weeks from now, five weeks from now,
four weeks from now,
there's another bastards somewhere on
this planet training and he's gonna meet
you at a certain point and a certain
time and your whole family is going to be
there and everyone you went to school
with is going to be there and he can do
some shit that you can do and you know
what you've done to people that might get
done to me. Absolutely. It's, and it,
it will, it's just a matter of time.
Is this the time? Is this at the
time? Maybe not. Hopefully not.
We're going to train for it to be not and,
and not to be,
but it couldn't be the time,
you know? So it, it's, it's
a, it's a head trip. Imagine,
fuck. And as soon as it's over, just
like anything else, it's like, you know,
you want to jump right back
in there. Oh, I could've done,
I would've, you know, x, y,
and Z. There's all these other things that
we could have done better. Let's do it.
Let's schedule another one,
boom and scheduled. Oh Shit.
Now all of a sudden the head trip kicks
in again as soon as it's scheduled.
And it's, you know, personal experience
of course. But every fighter,
almost every fighter, because not
every, but almost every fighter,
it's the same thing. It's the same
script over and over. It's a, it's,
there's an interesting term that a fighter
takes when they realize they're never
going to be the best and they're
just sort of doing it to fight.
They're just going to take fights.
Yeah. You know, and that's a, that's a,
it's a completely different turn.
They'd become a different fighter. Like,
you could almost see their color
change, you know, they just, they,
they go from being this streaking like
a thing that's constantly improving to
something that levels off and in
fact usually dwindles a little bit.
Sometimes guys get a little bit better.
I mean it varies on the athlete,
but there's young guys had come up and
there's one beating or to beatings that
they get somewhere along the
line and make them realize like,
you're never going to beat
this guy. Not, you know,
I'll take it out of him and may cause we,
we have close contacts but boxing
look at James Kirkland. Yeah.
Shooting Star right. Came in and the
gate, you know, he was the next big thing.
Yeah. Had a little bit of
trouble. Lifestyle travel
outside the ring and you know,
took a pretty good beating.
Now just he's kind of,
is he maybe maintaining but
probably degrading, didn't
he? Um, didn't he have a,
have a real tough fight recently?
Um,
had I not hear about that? Um,
the fuck is the tall kid hall.
Williams motorcycle crash paralyzed.
It's a heartbreaking. How can a man,
and that kid had such a tough
career. I mean, look who we fought.
Look how well he did.
Couldn't get a fight.
Nobody would fight him because he's such
a tough son of a bitch who was one of
the most dangerous and
feared guys for years.
And then he slowly started to slow down
and then, you know, Martinez got him.
You have a big left hand. He had some
tough fights, man. But you know that he,
the dude had a crazy work rate too. I
mean, nobody out punched Paul Williams.
That guy would come in.
Yeah, it was ridiculous.
Some credible winky. Right. There's
another guy. Doesn't get enough credit.
What a technical boxer. That guy
is so smart. So good defensively.
You know the shell that he
be. Yeah. Hands up high man.
He broke a lot of dudes down with that.
Just with sheer technique and skill.
He's a real skillful boxer.
I appreciate him like as a professional,
I see what he does and like that's a
real goddamn professional fighting Tarver
soon or I see the billboard, I'm pretty
sure I could be wrong. Wiki rights. Right.
And Tarver. Yeah, that's good
fight. They're both are good.
You know, that's a good,
you know, even as far as like levels of
their career to yeah, I'll watch that.
Tara is doing real well at heavyweight
and you see that had a couple of
heavyweight fights. Why is winky
writing him fighting then names money,
you know winky, right? Doesn't give
a fuck. Right. He'll fight anybody.
He always has called people out. Yeah.
Cause Tarver looked real good as a,
as a heavyweight.
I forget who the fuck he fought but he
beat the shit out of somebody. Yeah.
Beginner treadmill,
workout jumping.
Cause I don't want to leave you
hanging warm up. Five minute walk,
three miles an hour round,
one 32nd jog at five miles an hour to
minute walk at three miles an hour.
And you repeat that one,
two, three, four rounds.
And the cool band is a simple five minute
walk, three miles an hour. Anybody.
Everybody can do that or their own
version of that. So I'm a coach.
Here's The format I'm coaching you to
do it. Maybe you're one mile an hour,
you know,
a 32nd job and then a two mile an hour,
32nd jog and then one mile an hour,
two minute walk.
Do you have something that can be
adapted to an elliptical machine? Um,
obviously you wouldn't be able to regulate
the miles an hour as cloak closely.
Or the intensity is the Watson, an
elliptical machine. You know, there's,
there's all of the machines have a
way of regulating intensity, right?
And displaying it to you even on the
rower hadn't rows per second or per minute
or whatnot. So you can do the
same thing with rose as well.
You can do the same thing.
Like Joey was talking before,
y'all in your neighborhood, you walk
out your front door job to one mailbox,
walk to the next to jog to the mailbox,
walked in the next tape.
Most plots are evenly sized
in most neighborhoods.
I got a big hill on my street that
I'm scared of that I didn't ever run,
but it's fucking huge.
It's a,
it's a scary hill hill to one house and
walked back down. Don't do it that way.
When you, when you do a hill sprint
though, what is the rule like what do you,
what should you do? Should you run for
30 seconds? Should you run for a minute?
Like what's the, what's the smart way
to do it all depends. I picture cycles.
I break everything down in the
cyclists, a picture, three weeks cycles.
What are we trying to accomplish
over the next three weeks? Well,
I want to develop explosive power and
you have to re quads, glutes, hamstrings,
calves or whatnot. Maybe just speed
off the line. Maybe it's enduring.
So why are we going to the hill? You
know, and then we determine what the,
what the intensity, what the
volume is going to be. Um,
and it every three weeks it should change.
So you can find another area that you
want to improve and then peak that out.
Then maybe go back to the first area
or find a third area. Peak that out.
So you're constantly
peeking out a specific
area with strict rules.
What is the one thing that you take
out a fighter's diets most commonly
processed foods. Without
a doubt. You know,
I'm an advocate of earth grown
nutrients is a term that I like to use.
Is that like Paleo Diet type shit?
No,
but Paleo uses earth grown nutrients,
so EarthCorps nutrients.
It's like it's whole foods.
But when you say whole foods pick people,
picture supermarket chain,
whole foods also sells conventional food,
not just organic earth.
Neutrik earth or nutrients means this
came from the earth unadulterated by man.
I walked out my backyard,
I pulled it out of the stream with my
bare hands and pulled it out of the ground
and I didn't even plant the seeds. Let
say it just naturally grew right there.
That's EarthCorps. And the closer
we can get to that, the better.
So what I try and do with my athletes or
clients or anybody I deal with is I try
and make suggestions and tips
and then from my experience,
try this instead of that,
you're gonna use a high fructose
corn syrup based Ketchup.
When you can get this one right over here,
you can make your own with tomatoes and
some vinegar and some salt. And you know,
maybe a little bit of a Guy Bay on your
own stope tastes exactly the same or the
earth grown one tastes a heck of
a lot better, you know? So yeah,
that's the thing that I try
and do with the athletes.
But you're okay with Pasta
Pasta? Yeah. Yeah. Um, pasta be,
because athletes require a lot of sugar.
It's a lot of fuel. Turbos Wednesday.
Um, we do, I call, you know, a refeed
Wednesday night, which is typically,
it's a comfort meal. So we placate the
emotional side, the emotional eating side,
even during training camps,
like light candles and shit,
if that's what's necessary,
you know, you know,
recommend maybe the athlete does it
with their wife or their family or their
girl, they're their friends, they're
the games on or whatever it is.
So you can do it any way you want. Glass
of wine at the table with the family,
you know, any which way you want
to do. It's the emotional side,
but also nutritionally the athletes
getting everything that they need.
So I like to make my pasta with
chemo and not a Keema Pasta.
Just straight keenwah you know
lots of people. Yeah, it's awesome.
Lots of people dig it. So it's,
it's a pasta night in theory,
but it's not pasta noodles. It's not Zeni.
It's not, you know, in any of that stuff.
Although you can't do it, you can get a
brown rice if you want to go gluten free.
So this keen wa it's Keenwah Pasta.
Is that what you're saying?
Like the actual pasta itself can use it.
I prefer just straight cane loss.
So it looks more like a Chilean.
Me I've been using for a while now,
just mixing it with vegetables and stuff
like that. It's still confused though.
So there's no pasta. There can be pasta,
but you're calling it pasta pasta.
It's a refeed night. So we were talking
about, but you can certainly use pasta.
Okay. But it's cane while
it's not possible place the
Pos. Right, right. But I'm,
what I'm confused and when I was asking
is pasta. Okay. Actual white paws,
Barilla Pasta, Spaghetti, Spaghetti,
that certainly can be used.
It can be it or a brown,
right.
Round Rice space pasta or a
tapioca based gluten free pasta.
Or Quinoa Pasta or maybe just keen one
noodle noodles by itself or maybe no
noodles at all. You're just going to
have the sauce, which is a red sauce,
tomato base peppers and onions and
garlic and herbs and spices and all those
good things thrown in there too. What
about a Zico Pasta? Yeah. Awesome.
I love that. Good stuff. Yeah, I've
been using that a bunch lately. Okay.
Is there any benefit to taking like
plain white pasta or taking as ego pasta
like carbohydrate wines? Absolutely.
Carb load glycogen stores. Oh No.
I'm saying which is which one gives you
more benefit would what does you'll give
you more benefit? Would straight
white pasta give you more benefit?
I would lean towards the [inaudible]
because it's closer to the earth grown
nutrient category and it's,
it's higher in a variety of nutrients
where if you go just the straight durum
wheat pasta, which is like a standard
Barilla pasta where you getting any,
you know, olive garden and
whatnot. There was a high, yes,
there's a high glycogen content.
So if you're only goal is glycogen stores,
then you can certainly
get that from the pasta.
But if your goal is to get glycogen
plus fiber plus essential fats, plus,
you know, vitamin B or whatever
the heck else is in there,
and then you go to the [inaudible] and
you keep getting closer back to the earth
because there's more vital
nutrients contained in that.
But what's clean wall he wants to, it's
a grain. And what's it taste like? Wood.
It's delicious.
King was kind of it.
It takes on the flavor of
what it's being served with.
So I made a recipe name when
I was working with Mike Pyle,
when he fought her cart. Almeda and the,
you know, I come up with the recipes.
I'm Italian dude, like grow kid
in the kitchen. I'm rolling. No,
we're making simple as, you know,
fried no one in our kitchen. And uh,
been doing it my whole life.
So I worked with these guys,
pile lives a few miles from me and Vegas
go over his house where I would've been
eat for dinner. Start missing
some recipes. King La,
I got some keen ground
Turkey, asparagus, Renna,
onions and mushrooms chopped each
one. I uh, you know, light saute,
low heat so it tastes you don't
kill all the nutrients. Low heat,
saute the vegetables. How long do you
saute something to not kill the nutrients?
Um,
man,
as long as it takes for it to kind of
soften up or get to the flavor that you
want.
Like a peppers and they have a really
hard exterior outer shell so you actually
want to saute the pepper is a little
bit to break it down to unlock the
nutrients.
Otherwise it's going to digest through
and it's going to fall out really.
And you won't get all that. So it actually
is better for you to do that, to cook,
to cook peppers in, in certain cases.
Isn't it the case with tomatoes as well?
If there's something that gets
activated in tomatoes when you cook it,
that doesn't, when it's when it's raw,
I'm not sure specifically on tomato butts.
Things like spinach.
Most vegetables with an outer layer,
you will unlock a more nutrients
when you actually heat that up,
but not always because you still want to
have them raw and fresh because there's
a ton of other VI, other vital nutrients
and it's called lycopene. Lycopene.
It's an antioxidant and it comes
from cooked tomatoes. Julie,
if you want to add good local
place as good Kim law, swingers,
I usually always get the side of can
want and it's good and the Abbott Tuna
Salad there where it's just like tennis
out on lettuce and stuff and has,
it's on a bed of kin law and I always
get double Chenwa and that's like one of
the best salads that you can get around.
Know they got a,
they have Jamaican jerk chicken
would keen wa it's the, that was the
closest I could have.
If I don't want to have pasta,
if I would just want to try it one time,
like what's the closest I
could have for the head,
you know what I'm saying like that I
could just eat like a pasta and not really
trip on it. And it's like
when I like lamb, uh,
10 minutes later I'm fucking tripping.
I just want to eat something and not trip.
What can I eat that that's
closest to pasta? No fucking Tofu.
Cause I have a heart attack McKean whites.
It's no idea you're going to serve him.
Keywan he's going to come back in here
and scream for 15 fucking watched.
And I was like a girl.
Let me tell you,
it's Mozzarella cheese.
We'll fucking pasta sauce and real pasta.
He'll fucking hippies scanning
some fucking spaghetti.
My fucking hamp put curry
in my spaghetti and clamp.
So as I talked to that bitch for
six years, my mother, fuck I am.
You understand what? You
fucked up. One of my recipes,
Stacy poker Ludo had the worst mashed
potatoes of all time when you had to talk
to her for a fucking year on Thanksgiving.
That's how serious I take this shit.
So let's say,
so I should maybe just stick to the
spinach pasta and go from there.
Water myself down. Let's, let's back
up a second because what's your goal?
Don't tell me what you want. What do you
mean? What's our goal up pasta. But I've,
since I left the east coast, now
I, I'm okay with once a week. Yeah.
And I don't have to have
sausage and meatballs. I'm okay.
But you hear what he's saying, what it was
he saying? He's saying, what's the goal?
What's the sweat? He's always saying,
what's your hope? A little bit.
Maybe just to help a little bit. What
do you recommend? How bad it was?
A bowl of pasta every week, but help but
help what? Your heart, your cholesterol,
your uniqueness.
What?
It depends on how close you are to the
brink or how far you are from your goal
or how close you already your goal.
Just eat healthier pasta with the Turkey.
Like I liked what you, what you want
in the book. It's fucking delicious.
And the chilies fucking smoking too. If
you make those recipes, you're golden man.
And you had the gluten free option.
You've got the Vegan option,
you got the athletes.
I ain't gonna lie to you the first two
times I made the past, I used fucking,
you know, Ron zoning blow
transition. That's fine.
I've got to go rock zone and he's
been around for 30 fucking years. I,
he's got to know Mike Dolce two fucking
years. I got to go with Ron Zoning.
That's my fucking man.
If I loaned me the number two,
I don't like that string with Joey.
I mean this is a,
an uncomfortable moment here, but I got
to confront you on this because well,
we got here is a guy who was
like a nutritional expert.
You're using them as a sounding board.
No, no, no, no, but honestly, brother,
you know what you got to do. No, no,
no. I'm asking him what's better for me.
I'm not trying to be funny with them.
I'm asking him what's better.
If I like pasta,
what is the closest thing I could have
if I wanted to have a little healthy?
That's my homie Joe. A little healthier.
It's my fucking question and that's it.
A little healthier.
Donald fucking saves.
I'm telling you this cut me off.
He would stop me.
I never find the guests never sold to you,
Joe.
I just want to hear him
talking about nutrition.
You know I'm a fat fuck and maybe I
like to explain to the fucking running
technique,
but he said when
he confronted you, he said, I
pulled them with the fucking goal.
Was your playing law and order?
I'm saying to him [inaudible] I to fucking
maybe eat a little healthier pasta.
That's why I don't eat
the meat of the sausage.
Is there any way to make
it a little healthier?
Maybe the spinach pasta maybe the whole
week without suffering that much and
when I taste the whole wheat, am I
going to go fucking dolce? What I'm,
I'm getting back.
He was past the goal of the pasta.
What's your goal exactly?
What's your life goal?
Where are we trying to
go with your health?
With our fitness to 70 and
my head was too fucking big.
I was going into meet people.
They thought I had cancer.
I swear to fucking God dog.
They get to tell.
That's why I went in and I started
doing the upright rows to fill this in a
little bit now because
it got so fucking skinny.
I thought it was going to put
one of those voice machines.
That's what people are looking at.
Me and auditions and meetings like I was
going to put a voice machine so when I
hurt my nemesis, just the
consequences of having a one man show.
I booked up this area here a little
bit. Right. Needs to be 280 oh, I know.
I read the fucking thing. Not
lost 110 pounds. How's the fuck?
Didn't you eat all that shit in one day?
That's 19 year old died.
That's when you're whacking off.
Twice a day.
You're fucking drinking and you're
fucking somebody eight times a day.
That thing that you were eating was a May,
a pepperoni pizza at night
with a provolone on it.
The last snake, he can't eat that
no fucking way. 10 years ago,
maybe that diet that you eat now, what
do you mean? Years ago when I met him,
we went to the Miami Improv.
My jaw dropped. When you
order food, I fucked him.
My jaw drop. Joe Rogan. Why?
Because you ate three entrees.
It's still this mother fucker. I'm sorry,
Mister Dolce talk that you just ate.
I ate fucking egg Omelet, you know, with
eggs. No fucking egg whites, cheese.
I mean the Diet wasn't being,
I feel like I work out hard.
I eat whatever the fuck I want to eat.
And when I'm done with a show,
especially two shows, I'm hungry man. I
eat a lot of food. A lot of stake. Yeah.
Are you Paleo guy? Yeah,
well I don't follow it 100%,
but the majority of my diet is essentially
most of what I tried to eat is just
salads and meat. That's most
of it. I try to eat. Yeah.
And then I'll throw in a little bit of
pasta here and there every now and then,
or if I'm on the road and
I'm going to run, you know,
I eat what I can to try to stay
healthy. Sure. Always supplement,
supplement every day. Counseling a lot
of fish, oil, multivitamins, keylated,
minerals,
the whole deal.
I take a a gang of shit all day
long and I drink Kale shakes.
I tried to drink them every
day. Sure. So, um, that's, uh,
that's the majority of what I
do. I, um, but I think what,
what,
what you were bringing up with Joey's a
real good point that a lot of people say,
oh, I just want to Sorta, they got it.
They're kind of dabbling in the
idea of improving themselves.
And the real way to do it is you got to
write down what the fuck you want and
then go after it because otherwise you
live in sort of a wishy washy world.
You know, if you decide I'm going to
get down to bang, I'm going to do this,
I'm going to run a marathon in less
than five hours, I'm going to, you know,
whenever the fuck it is, you got to
write that shit down and go for it.
What I tell people is the best
advice it is,
I,
I've ever heard is the best advice I ever
came up with is it live your life like
you're the hero in your movie.
And right now is when the fucking
movie starts and your life is a shitbag
disaster.
Like every fucking Arnold sports nigger
move where he wakes up and makes a
blender full of pizza and ice cream and
that's what he, you know what I mean?
Those guys were like on the brink,
they put the gun in their mouth and they
put it down so you see a photo of their
daughter. Pretend that's you.
Pretend you are right now.
You're in the part of the movie that
starts and it shows you as a fucking loser
and just decide not to be a loser anymore.
Live your life like there's a documentary
crew following you around and you are
analyzing your own behavior to what you
would want to do so that your kids one
day would look back at it and,
and,
and see that documentary and
look on it with pride. Like, Wow,
my dad was a bad motherfucker. He
really did what he had to do. Wow.
My mom really got her shit together.
I love a success story,
but even more than a success story,
I like a dude who fucks his life up and
then gets it back together again. Story.
Those are my favorite stories.
And the way to do that,
you've got to write shit down.
You got to think that you are the
hero in your own fucking movie.
And then you get to sit down and
you've got to write shit down.
Write down what you need to do.
Most people play the role of the
victim in the movie, right? Yeah.
This life is fucking me over,
man.
I could have had this and I should have
had that. And why does this guy get that?
And why does that guy get this?
And all things that are completely
unrelated to you, all things that you,
you find other people's success as a
downfall on your own existence instead of
being inspired instead of
choosing to be positive,
instead of like improving constantly on,
on the direction of trying to achieve
whatever the fuck you have written down
and you just sit around and spiral,
you know,
there's nothing more miserable than
sitting around someone that's fucking
complaining all the time. And he's
one of the most annoying things ever.
Everybody hates it.
When someone just sits around and they
complain about their life and they don't
do Jack Shit about it and
you tip toe around it, you
don't know what to say. Well,
she gets upset when you bring that up.
I don't want to bring that up and you
want to go, you fucking crazy bitch.
You know what's wrong with your life?
Stop.
Stop announcing it to everybody else
and go out and fix that shit and that's
tough love. Tough love is what
everybody needs. Me included.
That's the only good thing about
like assholes on the Internet.
Sometimes they say things.
That's right. Yeah.
Sometimes Kuntz we'll say shitty things
to you on the Internet about a show you
did or a thing you said or you know,
oh the fucking neck
choking me on the podcast.
You're an asshole for even thinking
like that and you know part party you is
like, fuck you. Who the
fuck are you? But you,
you feel bad if things are correct,
you feel bad.
If someone nails Ya,
you'll feel bad if you really did,
if you didn't do anything
wrong and someone actually
a content is just like they
look like a crazy person like B.
You have to be able to have that honest
assessment of yourself and the only way
you can do that as you're taking
account of yourself all day long,
you're taking account, you're writing
down what the fuck you need to do.
You're doing it. You have a mindset that
you want to maintain throughout the day.
Don't
let the world maintain your mindset.
You choose what mindset that you are going
to maintain and I fucking do that for
sure. That's it. I tell you
words of wisdom by Joe Rogan.
I got on Twitter yesterday that said that
whenever I was on a podcast where you,
we were racially insensitive. Why
was that? And he didn't. He didn't,
he wasn't a Douchey,
are sensitive about the douchey thing
to have and it was seven in the morning
and I'm one of those guys that,
you know what you want early, man,
I want to rob me up at eight.
You want to round me up at 11 go,
well let's seven don't fucking
around me up, dawg. I'm smoking dope.
I'm playing with the cats. I'm drinking.
Cool. I'm having a good old time solo,
like a doctor,
you know,
giggling by myself and stupid jokes I'm
writing and all of a sudden this guy
sends me this and I look at it
and I go this, fuck. You're right.
He's right. I'm fucking
racially insensitive every
day. And I wrote back to,
you're right,
but at least I had racist.
Then you got a right
to say something to me.
But because we're racially insensitive
and I'm a sensitive to my own race,
you know his, his, I don't even, I
don't even like my own race. Yeah, no,
it's the way.
I don't mostly Italian with a little bit
of Irish and I avoid most Italians and
most hiring shy. They're five crazy
genetics. I don't like my race.
So there I think the idea of being
racially insensitive is ridiculous because
what they're getting upset at you is
pointing out real shit about races.
The pointing I real shit that you think
is funny that you sing and if they get
upset at that, that's
on them, man. You're,
you're attaching yourself to something
you have no fucking control over and you
even have pride, which is one of
the most ridiculous things ever.
I'm fucking pride that I'm from
this part of the ground. You know,
it's just the stupidest thing ever. The
idea that, you know, I'm a proud this.
I'm a proud dad as a proud Greek.
Shut the fuck up. Just shut up.
Shut up with your dummy.
You fucking individual on planet earth.
Stop it putting too many later
on himself cause they're pussies.
If you put a tape recording in my room,
you like Joey, you fucking racist.
But then if you look at my walls,
you're like, you ain't fucking racist.
You got it.
We've got Bruce Lee on this wall.
You've got Richard Pryor on this wall.
I'll tell you where Hendricks on this
fucking wall nationalism is sorta even
kind of admirable.
Kind of creepy,
but kind of admirable is Brazil
because they are so nationalistic.
They love Brazil so much.
Man.
I had never been to a country
that's so pro their country.
Then Brazil passionate. Right?
Oh my God. It's incredible. Yeah.
They're fucking more passionate
about their nationalism.
Any country I've ever been a part of, I
wish that was here. That passion, right?
That example from Brazil
came over here to America.
I think we need a little bit of that.
As long as it's not against
other countries. My,
my issue is not with passion and pride in,
in the individual country.
It's you against the,
the rest of the world that think
that's fucking pointless and nonsense.
That that shit drives me nuts.
Nuts, such shit. And you know,
but there's is a funny thing,
like when I was in jersey,
somebody was fighting and somebody was
yelling USA. Then I thought about what you
told me about Brazil when Mike
Powell one by one, they were yellow.
I'm a fag or yelling. What was the
word I see? I go, or some fat guy.
No,
or something like that.
I go and the translator thought
they were chanting Ciga. No,
they thought they were chanting junior
dos Santos, his name and I said,
I don't think that's what
they're saying. Yeah, like she,
she didn't want to say like what
what they actually were saying.
It's funny because now if you go to a
little league game or something like that,
you can not even allowed to say
nothing negative like swing the ball.
You can't say nothing. In today's
society, the way they bring up these kids,
if you go to a stadium now to watch
a baseball game or football game,
it's a bunch of fucking people.
You can ranch dressing except for
the Dodgers state and you're like,
who were they were, they were fucking,
you got to go there with fight gear on,
but fucking everywhere else it's pretty
fucking decent. Like nobody says nothing.
It's not like, hey you mother. When
I was a kid and I go to Shea Stadium,
does fucking Christ Stir Boston Games
in the 70s they'd throw you off the
fucking balcony. Now we live in
a society where you go to a game,
people pay 300 for a ticket and
they're well behaved. In Jersey.
They were a little fucking crazy,
but that was the craziest you somebody
that had a heart attack on the side,
something had fights.
You mean somebody was fighting and when
[inaudible] was fighting so many had the
hardest time had somebody,
somebody dropped from drunkeness,
one of those fucking loud a Jersey deals.
The guy behind me kept yelling,
looking for work,
and then he would sit down and pass out
for 10 minutes looking for as my uncle.
He didn't even know it was fine.
He just kept saying looking for work.
That's the cool thing about live events.
The cool thing in the bad thing,
it's like you might get lucky and sit
next to Joey Diaz or you might get fucked
and sit next to a couple of drunk
assholes. Absolutely. Most likely.
Possibly. It depends. We
never know though. It's,
it's interesting how different parts of
the country have like very distinct ways
of gathering and crowds to
like east coast. There are
a lot more aggressive. Man,
I would hate to be in your face.
Want to compete.
I would hate to be in Jersey this week
cause that is the worst type of crowd in
Jersey. What is it? What's this week that
king's a plane in the fucking finals.
Let me give you an example. Team.
The hockey team with Jersey,
when they won last time they went,
they won and they went to every bar in a
50 mile radius with the Stanley Cup and
it had a drink. And then I was
thinking about when I was a kid,
you know how people say to you now
owe America American footballs weak.
Fucking uh, uh, rugby is the sport.
You know what though? I grew up,
I played street hockey and Jersey and
one of those leaves for three weeks and
that was one time where I actually
doubted my man at the age of 13.
I did that for three weeks because
it's not hockey sticks and sneakers.
There's another variable
involving this cars,
com cars and you don't get,
you ain't real until you get hit by a car.
You know what I'm saying? Like that's
how you get props. Like dog, which Joe,
he got hit by a car but he
was playing next Tuesday. I,
that's how you got props
by getting hit by a car.
Like people would smash into til bro
Breaks weren't good back then either.
Listen, when you broke a Cadillac, a
glass, not a windshield because I want,
understand what I'm saying?
People when you dented a fucking Cadillac
grill in the 70s you want going to a
hospital that's an instant fuck my name.
You know,
squeezing the ball for the rest of
your life though with different causes.
It's not like hitting the fucking Hyundai
now with a thing. Bends a little bit.
Right. I used to play street hockey with
Tom Mccann, hockey sneakers, Tom Mccann,
especially black bottoms.
So you would stick dog and they had
these things where it was just you played
for your neighborhood, like
for your block, like dirty
a street. Had a team. Again,
it's 51st street and you would walk
over there where your hockey sticks,
no roller skates and
there wasn't a street.
And if you were in the middle of a
fucking oh role and the car was coming,
you that mother Fucker,
you either had to wait,
he was hitting you and somebody
would get hit once a fucking month.
And that was like your badge of honor.
Like those times,
like he got hit by a car blog.
His head went through the side of a
glass and he's coming back to play on
Tuesday.
That was this week in Jersey.
You do not want to be in Jersey
and the plane in La. So this week,
like Wednesday night, you ain't get no
sole out. You're going to sell out. Well,
I'm going to sell out.
We're going to do fucking great.
But the rest of the city you'll be
fucking deck. There's the king's a devils.
The Devil's kingdom starts Wednesday.
That's amazing. I didn't even know today.
Huh? Somebody it was like, yeah, the
kings are playing in the finals in Jersey.
I don't know where they're playing on
Wednesday, but whenever the fuck it is,
you don't want to be. So it's the
kings are there. The hockey team,
I didn't even know that they
had a hockey team members,
but they are the devils Harris Devil.
The Devil's are from Jersey.
Think the king kings. Oh,
La Kings, right. That right.
So remember Harris Pete used to work for
the kings. Harris. Pete worked for them.
He used to, he used to be
like a hockey coach with them,
so he knew all those guys.
I don't remember that.
I didn't know that. I just remember
he worked at the comedy store.
And then didn't you get in a bad
motorcycle accident when? I Dunno.
I think he hurt himself.
He used to drive a all the
way up the coast and his bike,
but I'm pretty sure he wrecked.
Okay.
That's so sad about Paul
Williams, man, young kid.
What do you know about promising? I just
saw the headline and read the story yet.
John. Not much man. How
the story, his brother,
you're on a fucking motorcycle in
2012 what's he doing on a motorcycle?
Awesome Burger on a motorcycle. Got
millions of dollars. It's in the contract.
I understand you want to be evil
can eat well. You know what?
Go out to a fucking circle out in the
swamps and ride your bike around in
circles with the elm and the chicken.
Have a suck good Dick.
But the drive a motorcycle in today's
society and my heart goes out to you.
Seriously. Especially Joe Rogan.
You'll see them on the phone.
Borrow five cause yeah,
doing 90 in between because when you're
stuck in bumper to bumper, scary. It's so,
you know a different world.
They live in a different world than
you live in their world is the world of
there on a ride and it's a a fucking
engine strapped between their legs.
They're risking life.
A red band.
What's the story you told me that they
played a fucking video for me. What?
The guy with the helmet
on where he chopped the car in
half. A little lady and I, yeah,
we played it on right here at the deer.
That should happen on a more,
you're chopping a beer and a half
with a fucking motorcycle. Yeah.
Yeah. That was a crazy video. What
guys just hit it?
Hit it just right.
He hit that thing just
right where he didn't die,
but he could easily fucking got shit flown
through the fucking air and landed on
his neck. Yeah. Motorcycles
are awesome, but fuck that.
Not Worth it. No, no. Protective
Outer Shell. It's so much fun. Well,
they're coming out with um, different, uh,
jackets and clothes that it's
made out of a particular impact.
Fiber that was,
tightens up and hardens on impact.
So you actually can fly through the air
or land on the fucking concrete and your
body like is protected from the
impact by this stuff. Hardening. Wow.
Like on impact. Yeah. I don't quite
understand it. I don't know how it works,
but you know, it's like how
the fuck does an airbag work?
I don't understand that either. I
mean it just, the impact senses.
They send something and it blows up this
fucking bag in your face to save you.
Well,
I think this is far more complex in that
the actual fabric itself has like that
property built into it.
Yeah, no, the airbag saving.
You remember years ago,
my mother was driving in the
snow 20 miles an hour real slow,
the car skid and she very lightly
taps a telephone pole. Boom.
Airbag deploys, breaks or nose.
Wow. That's a big problem.
And it kills kids in the front seat.
That's why you can't really, let's see.
It's a, it's a, it's a pro and a
con for some people, but whatever,
for saves a life,
I'll take a fucking broken those and
going through and I'm sure it's, oh,
it's a tons of lives. Well, if you've done
any training at all, your Ferdie broken,
you know, I was listening to that bad.
It's just stick some things in there,
open the passage up. The only problem is,
and you got to clean it out. Even then,
it's not that big a deal. This is
dolce. I didn't say any fights lately.
Yeah, Shit happens when you're the
ref and the living room. That's true.
How do you, do you ever try and talk
fighters into getting deviated Septum?
Sixt um,
I talk all about
my fighters into dealing with doctors.
You know,
I went all my guys to have a doctor
that they can go to and that can help
coordinate their health and keep on
top of it. So deviated Septum Septum.
If they're not getting enough oxygen,
we've got to address that.
There's so many dudes that are
out there doing that. Like mayhem.
Mayhem has no nose.
His nose is totally useless and
I tried to tell him to fix that.
Like you hear him talk,
you talked to her.
Maybe do like he's got that sort
of nasally tone to his voice.
It's cause his nose doesn't work.
He has to spray Afrin up there every day.
What does that stuff, was that what it
is? What does that some anti edition,
it opens up your, what is it
called? Africa? Is that what it is?
This stuff that opens up your nostril. If
he doesn't do that, he can't breed that.
It was known. That stuff is really
bad. It's addictive. It's the water.
The water's better cause I do the
other things so the water's good.
But you should boil that water because
there's been a bunch of cases recently.
If people getting parasites
and their fucking head, Huh?
Yeah. How bad. Real simple.
Real simple.
The fucking water.
Sometimes it's stuff that gets killed by
your stomach acids and it's no problem
whatsoever for that, but it's not
the same if it goes up your nose.
If he goes up your nose,
it actually becomes,
there's just people have gotten infected.
Cheers.
You got fucking pile of water.
Put some Vicks on that motherfucker
with a proud paper and it will open up
everything. Your eye balls, you would
see through walls with 10 minutes.
It wasn't a good old fuck.
Yes. Legal infections. By the
way, in Louisiana, especially,
Louisiana Department of Health and
hospitals issued a warning about improper
Neti pot use, which has been
linked to two deadly infections.
51 year old woman from Desoto
parish and a 21 year old,
20 year old man from St Bernard parish
died after using Neti pots containing tap
water to flush out their sinuses.
Both became infected with sweat.
This nod glary,
a flowery,
a parasite known as a brain eating Amoeba.
Jesus fucking Christ brain eating Amoebas
from your tap water that you get from
fucking porn water up your nose.
Water is poisoned.
Water is filled with poisoned
aliens that want to eat your brain.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
I mean,
that's essentially what we are dealing
with. You're dealing with a life force.
I mean, this isn't like, oh, you got
some birth control pills and your nose.
Now this is a, this is an actual
parasite. It's a living organism.
It lives in fucking water that you drink
and you pour it up your nose and eat
your brains out
though. What the fuck is it? What?
What? What should the next level you do?
We've got to put a pill in
water at the house in Boyle.
This shit is any good and out here,
I know there's a fucking scale,
a fucking scam. You got to boil this.
If you go to Arizona, tastes like dirt.
They say the best waters in Jersey,
New York Day. Cause they cleaned it.
I can't fucking see that
a Hudson. Yes. Holy Shit.
There's a lot of tests
linked to this shit man.
There is a lot of desks link to this
and it's all this same brain eating
parasite.
Wow. Penn Jillette did the thing
of bullshit where he did the bar,
the water bar in Hollywood,
and he was giving people water,
like telling them this is Walter from
Europe, the mountains. Meanwhile,
the way there was in the backyard,
I'd fill in the fucking bottles of water
hose and these mother fucking months
are like, oh, it's so Omni.
It was the shift from the uh,
yeah,
from the back. You fucking hoes at
the restaurant tap water. You know,
I don't trust Dick when it comes to this
best. Oh Yo. This stuff
gets into people's fucking,
this is killing people that swim in,
in fresh water.
Where in warm lakes, this is killing
people in Kansas. Jesus Christ,
two kids died because of this brain eating
Amoeba after swimming in a warm lake
in August. This is apparently
like really common. Huh?
Oh my God. What the fuck man? It's
don't go swimming in lakes out there.
People in your house.
Yeah.
Not Go swimming in lakes and stay away
from trees cause that Japanese beetle and
getting you fucking asshole
and biotic side out. Shit.
This is amending jaw foul
fell Litas Emmy Robotic Amjad
[inaudible] [inaudible] be ubic a m o e B.
I see.
How do you say that?
Amoebic Amoebic Ma,
m e I n men Joe in Cephalitis
men join cephalitis.
You know it's really no need to make
the brain eating parasite and give it
another fucking complicated name.
Why did they have late stage names?
You know they have like the
name that you call them.
Like you know this is
notorious B I g brain,
any parasite and then they have this
fucking crazy Latin bullshit that nobody
can say. It's like you are you talking
English to an English speaking person?
You Fuck?
What is this 70,000 fucking letter word?
The IRS creates those words, I
think. Yeah. What is dope? Yeah.
Lorazepam. Valium was a pan. Whatever
they have stage names stays names.
Just give me the fucking thing.
They think this parasite is man
created as it naturally occurs,
naturally occurring.
It's like,
you know what people don't understand
is when you see a lake, okay,
that is not just water
and fish. Okay? There's,
that's a a an ecosystem.
There's algae, there's,
there's plants that are growing in there.
There's all sorts of,
there's fish shit that something
has to eat that fish shit.
There's a lot of things going on
there. There's parasites. You know,
that's one of the reasons why it's
not safe to eat fresh water Sushi.
You have to be really careful
with freshwater Sushi like
salmon and things along
those lines. Even fish that are,
that migrate like Salmon, they get,
they get parasites, man, you,
you should really only eat like salt
water fish like tuna and yellow tail and
things along those lines. Like a lot of
people, like health advisors tell you,
you know there's certain amount of
people that are going to get worms.
They're going to get parasites
from eating Sushi is what it is.
Especially if you eat fresh water stuff,
you know,
we don't know where the
fuck that's coming from.
These could be coming from those farms
like farm raised fish are sure when you
have a reason wanting to see those things,
they're just swimming pools
filled with fish. Shit,
it's fish and fish shit and they're
throwing pellets in there and the fish eat
the pellets, dies their muscles.
So it is actually orange. Yeah.
That's the weirdest thing about
domestic domestic trout and salmon.
They don't even have the same color. Their
bodies. Yeah. Fuck is that man. I mean,
you know evil when it comes to food
as nutrition guy would've fucked.
Do you trust that?
Trust yourself?
I mean you go to whole foods or am I
getting the best meat available to me when
I go to Gelson's, am I gay and
I'm just using these two labs?
Do I go to a butcher back to basics aren't
my whole bucket cow like most people
are doing out in the Midwest.
They're raising their old cow and going
over there on the weekends and feed that
and chopping it up. I mean, why wouldn't
you trust start local? You know,
I was trying to start in your own backyard
on your property and then go to your
neighbor,
you know,
start making little circles from your
house and try and get your nutrients
as, as local as possible. That's
the best way to do it. And the,
eventually you stumble onto the food
chains like a whole foods or trader Joe's
or whatever else.
And then you have to be very specific.
Look for local sources
that they get it from.
What do you do when a guy's a Vegan?
That's awesome.
Do you think that's healthy?
Absolutely. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Just have to be careful
about, you know, as, as a,
is it healthy for all hundred
and 20 years of your existence?
Maybe or maybe not. Is it healthy if
you're, uh, a combat athlete and maybe,
or maybe not. Is it healthy, you know,
geographically where you're located.
Do you have a full supply of
all the nutrients necessary,
the plant based nutrients
necessary maybe or maybe not,
but veganism as a philosophy or as
as a goal I think is excellent. Um,
do we need meat proteins? Uh, they
certainly work very well, but you know,
there are other options that should be
considered and I think it's very unique
to the individual in your moment,
you know,
on in this space and time maybe
veganism is the right thing.
I like what I call Vegan modified
where we go through cycles.
I go through cycles. I go like three
days a vegan every three weeks or so,
or three months, a Vegan, you
know, a year. You know, I,
I play with little things like that, but
also other ways, you know, hardcore meats,
you know,
now you know,
I'm getting a little away from red
meats a little bit more lately.
So I'm kind of dabbling in other areas
more and more plant based things.
Would you like, uh, when you talk
to people about veganism, do you,
how do you set up like to make sure
that they get all the amino acids,
all the nutrition,
all the things just based on plants?
Like you have to be careful,
right?
Like it's not this like people to
understand like you can get protein from
certain things, but it's not
going to be a complete protein.
There's certain aspects of it that you're
not going to get that you would get
from meat. Absolutely. How do
you, uh, how do you monitor that
protein is broken down into amino acids.
So you have to look at me,
the nine essential amino acids. Are you
getting those in, in abundance, you know,
based upon your need, you know, what's
your, uh, your, your requirement.
How often are your
muscles rebuilding itself?
Let's say we'll talk about athletes, you
know, they have a demand on their body.
They break their, their muscles
down and they need protein in meat,
amino acids to rebuild that,
you know,
get it back to the baseline
and then improve from there.
Doing that as a Vegan is very difficult,
especially here in the United States.
North America,
it's very hard just because there aren't
quality vegan products available that
aren't genetically modified.
I think genetically modified
products do worse for you.
I do believe that you were worse for
you because we can't determine it can't
predict the outcome. We don't know
what the future result is gonna be.
I don't know what the long term uses.
And I think there's immediate distortion
to the way the body absorbs the
nutrients and by the word genetically
modified kind of explaining to people what
most people don't understand is that
there are certain plants that are
genetically modified for various
reasons and some of them are to uh,
avoid parasites.
Some of them are to not get killed by
pesticides so they can spray pesticides
over everything. I mean, tell some of
the, some of the other reasons why they,
it's profit is why they're
genetically modified.
The genetically modified so the plants
can grow bigger and stronger and faster.
It's pes is what genetically modified a
GMO Jim performance enhancing drugs for
plants. Exactly. That's exactly what it
is. And there was a toxic effect to it.
You know,
I don't believe any man can step in and
can alter what was naturally occurring
on the planet with a positive
outcome. You know? Uh,
I just don't think we have the ability,
I think we're fooling ourselves and the,
the scientists of the people
involved are fooling yourself.
What sort of general feeling to it?
Like they haven't,
they haven't done all the due diligence
as far as the longterm benefits.
And it seems like we, it's, it's
food. We're saying it's food.
It is food and everybody knows that food
is okay. It's not poison. So run with,
it looks like food tastes looks like a
photo of food more than it looks like
food. And that's the problem. Well, when
Monsanto gets involved, first of all,
they have patents on
essentially a patent's on life.
That alone is very strange.
I mean, what if, you know,
the idea is like stage to
do this for certain drugs.
Like that's how bath salts have become
legal is what they essentially did was
took something that's illegal and modify
it very slightly and then it becomes
legal, the ad one molecule to it and
then it's not the same thing legally,
so then it's okay. Well when
you, you do that with, with life,
like you're owning all the corn.
Like that idea is insane that they can
take corn and then they add a little
thing to the corn.
Now they own all that corn
because they created the fuck.
You create it. That's like going
up to a Porsche and you know,
and painting stripes on it and saying,
well I created this Porsche,
now I get the patent on this Porsche.
It's like it's complete total.
That's a terrible analogy.
I know I tried to say,
and you're pushing at the top of my head,
but the idea that they tried to,
they tried to patent pigs,
they tried to patent literally patent
pig parts because they're genetically
modifying pigs. They're trying to
patent a pig. They genetically modify.
Like these are like some really
unscrupulous dangerous ideas like these.
This is your, you're going to
go own life like what's next?
Are you going to take a person and
modify just one little strand and that
person's DNA and you made them from a a
Zygote that someone had left behind in a
fucking frozen lab. When people take
their embryos and they discard them,
are you sure there you're frozen and
bureaus are embryos are discarded?
What if someone comes along and adds
a few fucking molecules to them? Oh,
it's not a, it's not a person
anymore. It's a a human fuck bag.
I just take it around with me. It
doesn't talk. It can't go to work.
It just listens to me and
I get to fuck it. I mean,
and it grows to full
maturity in 24 months. Let's,
that's not outside the
realm of possibilities. It
sounds ridiculous. I mean,
it's obviously a joke, but if you
can, if you can patent tomatoes,
if you can patent,
if you can own the design to
something that all you did was altar,
that's crazy.
That's really crazy.
And these politicians that
have let this take place,
you mother fuckers are guilty.
You're all guilty,
you're all cops and crooks and you fucked
up the whole world because you started
a chain of events and that chain
of events due to fucking greed,
due to special interest
groups, due to lobbyists, dude,
all those assholes that laced your
fucking pockets and allowed you to allow
people to do something, you know
is fucking evil and against nature.
You know it is. They're going to
patent pig. Get the fuck out of here.
You crabs, the assholes. Crazy. Greedy.
Cons have set a chain of events in,
in place that might take down the
whole human race. Congratulations.
Because the thing about people,
man, when they start making money,
when they started making money with
something, whether it's from bombing,
people are poisoning people or once
you start making money at something,
it's very hard to change the law.
Very hard to stop that chain of events
because once they're in the money's
flowing, people are getting
greased. There's no motivation
whatsoever. Stop that.
And that's money. Big money.
Trillions of dollars worldwide.
More than the whole United States.
Condoms. Yeah. And once I Ryan was,
and then we usually pay him the
fuck off too. Yeah. This is a dirty,
the dirty world forever.
So what administration that they fucking
con what probably Reagan probably start
off with Reagan.
There's a lot of bad shit started with
the Reagan administration before that way.
A lot of bad shit started with Reagan.
It's in the pig. That is, that is that,
that was the first puppet.
That was the first.
We had a guy who made a living at a fake
in it and he became the main guy that
we needed to tell the truth.
He was a professional liar.
He's Ronald Reagan was an actor and
the actors, or are professional liars.
He was a really good convincing liar
and that motherfucker was the president.
And from there it all turned to shit.
And now today it's amazing.
Everybody forgets that.
Let me say a word when it started,
it doesn't say when I started here,
oh 1901 shizam son fucking
things up for a long time.
They started in St Louis and that crazy,
these crazy assholes.
And I bet you know what? I bet they
started off as a legitimate company.
He's trying to improve on
products. Sure. You know,
they probably would just try
and make better corn. Yup.
Probably trying to make a
better tomato that doesn't,
it doesn't rot out so quick.
They probably thought they were good
doing good things and then next thing you
know they're buying up.
Mark's take it over the fucking world.
200,000 Indian farmers have committed
suicide because of them. It's amazing.
Yeah. That's good. I got a
loophole for all of them. Yeah,
they did to the actual law.
They got a loophole for all of them
where they would not fucking do it.
That's what the law is. Beautiful. Because
we got, like you said, genetically,
so I put a put two leaves on top of
the fucking tomato and that's it.
I could change the fucking tomato.
Tomato has two little fucking leaves.
It doesn't have a step. Did you imagine
that shit? It's really ridiculous.
It's really ridiculous.
I never knew about that.
It's really ridiculous. It's
ridiculous that you're allowed
to do that. It's, it's,
it's criminal.
There's so many laws that are in place
that are just so spectacularly corrupt.
It's, it's hard to imagine that anybody
takes voting seriously at this point.
Who does take voting
seriously? Unfortunately, he,
I don't anymore. You know,
I don't hear any of my peers talking
about it with confidence. Like it matters.
You know,
people talk about politics and politicians
like they talk about reality TV. Well,
I think real anymore. All that hope
be changed. Shit. You know? Oh,
I hope he changing. You know, those were
Sarah Palin said about, about Obama.
How's that hope be changed
you think working out for you?
She said it's kind of brutal when
it's coming from a Dingbat like her,
but meanwhile she's fucking right.
He's on it.
This is ain't no ho be you going on.
We're doing the same God damn
shit economy's still sliding.
Everybody's talking about, oh,
the job market rebounds back.
They hired more government people.
That's it.
How bad is the job market and you guys,
the people you know are out of work.
Are you hearing about everybody hurting?
And I know the housing market is,
is garbage because I know
many people lost their home.
A lot of people in Vegas for UFC and
compare that that's cause I live in Vegas
cause all, as I say, I go to Cleveland.
When I go to Columbus, I gauge, you
look around, you know, we're here in la,
we're in the comedy business, the
movie business. We see ms Sadie's.
But that's just a short amount. You
know, that's why after the Sag merged,
I mean even shits hurt and fucking here.
But uh,
you know,
what's amazing when you look at it,
the election and after you
lived through the election,
like once you live through,
what's the guy, uh,
the guy that came on the chicks dress,
Clinton,
once you live through his election,
you really learned what the election
was all about and you learned that.
It's like when people look at a
sporting event, they want to gamble.
They look at the point spread.
That's the least of your fucking worries.
There's so many circumstances around that.
And when you look at an election to see
how somebody won, you know when Clinton,
they just involve them TV. Yeah,
that's it. You've seen them.
They involve the generation that didn't
think they had a vote and they just
involved it and you see the little
scams. It's a, they sell the sizzle,
not the steak, and that's it. And if
you keep buying into the fucking sizzle,
eventually one day, one day, you know,
it doesn't take long after two elections.
When you're 30 and you've seen
two or three elections to go,
nothing is changed by the time you're
30 you should see this and nothing's
really changed.
I'm going to go down there and drive all
people to vote or whatever the fuck it
is. I'm still registered in my
hometown in North Bergen, New Jersey.
I've had 19 fucking felonies and I
still vote there and an absentee ballot
because they don't give a fuck.
You got to kill somebody in Jersey.
They stopped voting, leaving, then you
vote to you, your spirit's fucking vote.
Absolutely.
Okay. Ready for this? Monsanto
made Agent Orange. Yeah. Yeah.
Isn't that. That's what's in the round.
That which is what's in the corn.
I they sprayed on crops of Vietnam
and all these fucking people,
including John, our driver in
Atlanta. Remember that guy? Yeah.
That guy was awesome.
Our driver in Atlanta, he was, he's sick
from Agent Orange. From Vietnam. Wow.
Yeah. Agent Orange. Oh. And
Ddt as well. That's cute.
They made DDT. Wow. What a crazy company.
That's ridiculous. They made me
began manufacturing DDT in 1944.
Oh my God.
The incesticide insecticide was a much
welcomed in the fight against malaria
transmitting mosquitoes. Hmm. And
then I guess it's not good, right.
Maybe develop for a good purpose
and bastardize into profit. Well,
it's really good for killing
mosquitoes and mosquitoes are cunts.
It is a fucking crazy cycle, man.
There's a war going on people,
all the vegans that are all,
uh,
you know that love animals
more than you love people.
That's where I draw the line. That's where
I think you people are fucking crazy.
If there's a team you should be on,
it's teen people 100%.
I don't think he should be on team
buffalo or team Chicago or anything silly
like that,
but as a race,
who the fuck can you relate to if you
can't relate to human beings and people
that are like, there was a mountain lion
and got shot in Santa Monica last week.
People protest. Oh my God, they went
crazy. Yeah. Why did you shoot it?
The woman was like on Facebook,
this lady was like,
I would gladly take a
bullet for a mountain lion.
You understand the emotion, right?
The love she has maybe for nature,
for life in itself, but the lack of love
she has in life with humans. With humans.
Yeah. I mean humans, your own, you
know, if it was the a family member,
so she said before person,
she said,
I would gladly take a bullet for a
mountain lion or a bear before I would a
person. Hmm. Meanwhile, bears
don't give a fuck about you.
If you got shot right in front of a Bam,
boom, you're fucking headaches bloated.
The bear would walk over, sniff.
You look around, start eating.
You are eating your end trails. Very
sample. That's what the bear would do.
That sweet mama bear would start
eating your asshole. Call her,
call her little kids zone of mountain
lions. Don't give a fuck if you get shot,
you dummy you ridiculous bitch.
And this is a tear bullet.
Of course it is out here.
It's where people are soft.
It's crazy out here walking
in with restaurants.
It's like walking into a
reality show set and you know,
having dinner here last night was
a trip and breakfast this morning.
And what way do you just walk in and
you see like it's like cast members,
perfect outfits they do
with the scarf around,
you know what I mean at dinner.
And he's got the cute little girlfriend
who was all done up looking like he's
straight off MTV, the hair's perfect. And
he's talking to he acting like he's uh,
you know,
adjacent silver wannabe smart he is and
how much more he knows and he's 22 years
on the planet then you know her,
cause she's only 21 and a half.
There's a lot of needy cons
out here. It's, it's nuts.
Everything with a performance
is, is crazy. It really is crazy.
Especially the ones that get ready
to look messy. But then this,
that's where this dude,
this is that they actually take an hour.
I don't want to look like I did myself.
I want to look like I walked out of a
fucking bomb shed. Let me walk out there.
They get the hair and they, they actually
moose it. So it, it is so fucking crazy.
It's nuts. It's fucking crazy. Thank
you for fucking those. Oh, Jesus. Yeah.
It's cool though. It's, you know,
it's like walking through the Matrix.
It is strange. Yeah. Uh, I, you know,
I try not to spend too much time in
Hollywood itself, but if you do you,
you sometimes be surprised at how blatant
it is. I was like, Jesus, is this real,
this seems like it's so
stereotypical, like, so stereotyped.
How did you guys not see
how goofy look Truman show?
It's like a big set and you know,
well I think reality shows have really
changed the culture significantly and
most of us don't understand
it or see it because you know,
we're out there in the world of standup
comedy in the world of MMA to very,
very real world.
But in here in California,
the reality is you can get
famous for fucking nothing.
And if you do have a good concept,
it's like I saw one where there was a
guy who has a bunch of pretty girls who
cut hair for him and
he has a reality show.
It's a fucking haircut place and they'll
wear bikinis and they cut hair and it's
on a HD net. I was like, Jesus Christ,
you just swinging at everything.
There's enough out there that all someone
has to do is be like semi outrageous.
And next thing you know there there
are professional personality, you know,
and maybe they don't, you know that
that attention desires unhealthy.
Like maybe it's like Judy Browning, you
know, like where it's coming from place.
It's probably not that healthy.
The re the ways lashing out like that.
It's absolutely a place of a lack of
discipline or a place of a lack of,
of love early on in his life or
whatever the fuck it is. And currently,
most likely. Yeah, currently.
Most likely. Yeah. I mean,
the last thing you want to do,
what to do like that is, you know,
put a fucking camera in his
face and take them dragon.
I've got to give him a hug. Go
drink some common meal tea. I mean,
how many guys went fucking absolutely
apeshit bananas that were on the ultimate
fighter a lot,
man.
Mikey Burnett maybe ran into the fucking
wall head first and broke his neck.
Fucked his neck up, man. Mike,
you put a helmet on and
ran head first into a wall.
Like you can't. Yeah, you can't do that.
Lock 16 dudes up in a house for six weeks.
Make some blame each other. Yeah. Made
them up full of booths. Incredible.
It's the craziest idea for a show ever.
The ultimate fighter is a genius fucking
program. Great TV. You know, like the,
the reason why Forrest and Stephan Bonner
went at each other so hard. They did.
Just some mother fuckers had been
standing each other down for weeks,
for weeks and weeks and weeks
training and staring each other down.
No one that they were gonna eventually
throw knuckles at each other.
So two pit bulls in the cage,
right? Is it the finals finals,
the ultimate fighter this weekend.
I'm not even going. No, I'm not going.
I'm doing Canada.
I don't do the FX ones anymore.
I don't do the fuel or the FX wants,
but I miss doing the finals
of the ultimate fighter.
It's fun indoctrinating these guys
and like seeing them, you know,
get their trophy and the fucking seen
how happy the art. That's a real journey,
man. To go in that house for all
those weeks and now it's 13 weeks.
Now it's even longer. It's nuts. It's,
these guys are locked away in time.
A long time.
A lot of them have families.
A lot of them have children
that they can't see.
That's three God damn months plus.
Yeah, that's crazy. You know,
you think it's hard going on the road
for a couple of no. Nothing. Nothing.
No book, no bell. Fireable no
Bible. No, they used to have,
they used to be able to read bibles.
Right. Is that true? Cut Up season.
They as a prop let me have one on
fight day and that's the only piece of
literature that was allowed on that
day. And I think cause ramp, you know,
worked it in some bed.
If you want to do something wacky though,
like the read Satan's Bible,
you know, read some fucking
six six, six sheets. Yeah.
Yeah.
You want it to get crazy.
You fucking wore eyeliner when you
fought and shit. That's the new gimmick.
Isn't it funny that you can legally
smoke a couple of cigarettes right before
you fought and nobody would stop ya? Yup.
So stupid and EPO is not illegal. Is it?
Is it, is it illegal? I don't, so I don't
think they screen for EPO. What's EPO?
Epo is a,
it's a performance performance enhancing
drug that cyclists are very fond of
because it increases the amount
of red blood cells in your body.
It basically mimics the effects.
Yeah.
There. I think that might have, yeah,
that only has the caffeine of a,
of a cup of coffee.
Five hour energy is predominantly B12.
One of the reasons why it works so well,
that's also what's also
in that shroom tech sport.
A shit load of fucking beat 12 and you'll
be like, ha, that's true. I'm tech boy.
You take four of those pitchers and
then you go work out in an hour,
an hour later,
go work out God damn man,
that it's B12 is fucking incredible.
And cordyceps mushrooms,
that's the mushroom that those
people in high altitude take.
They started noticing their cattle were
eating them and then being more active.
So uh,
people eventually start experimenting
with them and taking them and it helps
your body produce more ox or a absorb
more oxygen and you've tried it,
you've tried it out.
I love it.
I love a cognitive advantage by using
it or just the field of cognitive
advantage for sure. For from
this Alpha brain stuff. I'm, I'm,
I am really fucking a pussy with this
stuff. If I go on the road, I panic.
If I fuck up and forget this,
when I have them send me some to hotels,
you know I don't, I don't want to be
without this stuff. If I have the,
if there's like a show I have to do or
if I have to do a podcast or I have to
write, you know, I want my brain firing.
I don't, I don't, you know? Yeah.
You can be fine if you eat a
cheeseburger and don't eat healthy. Yeah,
you can be fine if you
only got three hours sleep,
I can perform on all those things. I
can do that. I can pull it together,
but we all know what's optimum.
You all know when we feel the best,
like you were saying,
when you go on the road,
that's a terrible feeling when you have
to fly in and then you have to do radio.
You're fucking exhausted and you
try to get some sleep that day,
but you don't really get enough and then
you've got to wake up and go do a show.
No, I'm talking about 10 years ago when
you flew into Houston on Tuesday night,
you went out to eat. You went
back to your room for the morning.
He used to go two hours radio. Remember
they used to be after the radio? Yeah,
we used to have so two days you didn't
fucking sleep. You slept it out by,
by the time Friday came,
you can't fucking think straight and
you got to chose to do. Yeah, the,
well that's the best thing
ever about the podcast.
So we don't have to do
a morning radio anymore,
although there are friends of ours though.
I still like to go on their shows like
opie and Anthony and you know, and,
and guys along those lines,
I mean there's
still a lot of shows.
I like to do Dale Dudley in Austin,
but fucking I need sleep man to sleep.
It's fucking important.
I tell you what,
some,
sometimes it's even good sometimes
to be a little unconscious.
I've had my best sets of two hours of
sleep. That drug induced the night before.
I'm talking about two hours because you
had a fly or you come into it with a
different attitude, right. Do you
really do, when you're unconscious,
sometimes you don't want to think about
what the fuck you doing, you know,
40 fucking nine years old.
I would go to New York with Joe a couple
of weeks ago and we're at a hotel and I
wanted to smoke and there was
a balcony and it was a cricket.
He mother fucking balcony and it was
small and I get out there in the first day
smoking two hits and I looked down,
do you know her?
Through the joint away and walked
back in. Oh my God. It was burned by,
but then the next night I went
out there and I hit it again.
I didn't look down and nothing happened.
I walked in like that and I said,
you know what? That's like our
lives. When we look at something,
sometimes it's better not to fucking look.
Just go in there and go, you know what?
Get me this fucking, he'll be on the
pill. There you go. Tubby, cock sucker.
What's up baby question. I got
in, then I got to go. Shoot.
I gotta ask you something because
I don't know what, first off,
what is the Paleo Diet? Paleo Diet
I think is happening and creation.
Paleo, Paleolithic period. The period
before agriculture. So meat. Yeah,
meat and vegetables. I'm the things that
grow and you know, and just animals.
Like today I had,
I had a protein shake for breakfast
and I had the tuna for lunch.
What kind of protein? Uh, the one
from fucking way from GNC. Okay.
Eight ounces of milk to ice cube
bull because it gets me going.
I can't leave the house without eating.
So I need something.
My blood sugar goes down, I
get dizzy and shit. Right.
So then for lunch I had a little
six ounce ribeye that I cuts fit.
I go to the butcher and I fry it up
with garlic with a little bit of fucking
spam and that's it. You know, I
like, man, I'm like Joe Rogan.
I like fucking a good steak.
You know,
I can't eat a 22 ounce sirloin no more.
Like when I was 22 in northern New Jersey
at the Berkshire, Diana, but I like it.
Eight ounce, 10 ounce strip. In your book,
you always use the Turkey
meat and you particular, well,
I think right now a lot of
people are too in this country,
red meat dependent and their source of
red and he's the wrong wrong source.
They'll go to Mcdonald's and that's
red meat to them. That's a burger.
That's good. You know, um, you know,
go to outback, you know, I mean,
I don't know the quality per
se, but I'm sure it's, you know,
pretty confident it's
not the highest quality.
And they'll eat excessive amounts of
that 12 ounce, 16 ounce, constantly.
Two meals a day, three meals
a day. They'll have bacon,
pork, bacon at breakfast.
The,
the,
the calorie content at the end of the
day is so much higher than some of the
leaner meats, the poultry that, Turkey
chicken, things like that. So, red meat,
certainly, if that's part of your
mindset, part of your culture,
and you don't have any preexisting
medical conditions, right? You didn't,
you're not barred from eating red meat.
Uh, for whatever reason, um, it, it's,
it's certainly fine, you know, it's fine
to have in there, but in moderation,
you know,
I think everything in moderation,
you should certainly rotate
through the lean protein sources,
the animal protein sources,
just like you should through the
plant based sources he had on Joe's
recommendation. A lot of these
guys, the ostrich Burger,
I took two bites in the fucking
delicious. It's so good. Ostrich Burger
talking about food. Oh, it's fucking
delicious. And I had two bites just to,
you know, like I said, I got
up the pantry shelf shit.
So I like the extra lean
Turkey meat man witches.
Like I just replace the meat with uh,
extra lean Turkey and just put a little
bit of the half of the packet of the
seasoning on it and it
tastes just like Manwich,
but it's extra lean Turkey and
dramatically less calories. Right? Yeah.
What do you feel about
supplements? Like, uh,
what kind of things you get your guys on?
You know,
the first thing we get them on is the
food and make sure they're eating a well
balanced diet of earth grown nutrients.
In a consistent,
uh, lifestyle. Once that's
been firmly established,
then we can start to determine
what supplements they may need.
Why do we start shotgunning supplements
in place of food and then start to fill
in the blanks with food. It should
be the other way around, right?
So we get that diet established first and
then we start looking at food or look,
start looking at supplements.
And honestly,
realistically the supplements are very
small and it's dependent upon the person.
Of course, some guys prefer supplements,
they have more of that mentality.
But the people that don't aren't already
biased towards supplements typically
don't want to take supplements and have,
you know, tremendous feedback, you know,
and you know, medical data that
we get blood work done there,
you know exactly where they should be.
So it really doesn't warrant
supplements in most of the cases.
And that's most of the guys I work with.
Do you go do blood work on the guys? I,
I suggested I recommended
I'm not a doctor,
but that's why I almost insist
now with all my athletes,
they worked directly with a doctor.
They get their blood work polled every,
you know, four to six weeks. Um, so
we can analyze the data. You know,
we constantly need to see where
the athletes had. It's like,
it's like if they're dropping
their hand when they bring it back,
health is the same way.
We've got to stay on top of everything
now when you see shit going down like
this Alistair Overeem thing where they're
checking him, not even post fight,
but during training when they did the
random drug tests on everybody and
Allister, it turned out that
he had taken some medication.
The story is that he had taken some
medication and it inadvertently had
testosterone in and he wasn't aware it was
going to get tested. Yeah. What do you,
what do you, how do you feel
about these sort of situations?
I think it's a lot of grand standing.
It's politics, it's bureaucracy. You know,
you test the guys at competition,
you know that, that's fine.
Unless there's some sort of
agreement beforehand, you know,
like they're talking about Adam and
blood testing, you know, whatever.
If that's the agreement, that's what the
athletes competing under, that's fine.
But I think like the, you know, surprise
drug tested the press conference,
you know, they're, they're setting
guys up to to pinch him. Um,
now should these guys be taking things.
That's,
it's a whole nother conversation
and without knowing specifics,
it's not my place to talk about it, but
I think it's really politics, you know,
probably comes
down to dollars or it comes down to ego
and it comes down to some sort of power
struggle instead of truly
trying to clean up the sport.
I don't think that's the
way to clean up the sport.
I think that's the way to kind of,
you know,
further agendas and I don't
think that agenda's, uh, on,
uh, you know, helpful. Yeah,
it does get weird when, you
know, becomes an ego battle.
Like I caught you and you're
doing something you're not
supposed to be doing and
you know,
it's like what,
where do you draw the line and what's
legal and what's not legal? I mean,
who gets to decide what is fair?
Why is creating legal creatine works?
Creatine is, creatine is a real
performance enhancing supplement.
It's legit. It works. Caffeine is you
just like caffeine is in k you? Well,
caffeine is a tricky one because you can
use a little bit of it. You know, we,
we covered that. That's a, that's weird
that they let you use a little bit of it,
you know. Let me ask you
something dog. What are the,
what does the general public pissed about
that the people would steroids while
they're trading a while they perform
vie Roger Clemens to this motherfucker.
Why are they mad it Roger Clemens.
Joe,
because he was pitching doing steroids
before he pitched. No, well, the,
the argument, what's really pathetic
is the argument is, first of all,
Congress got involved, which is
observed Congress, Congress baseball,
aggressional hearings.
They had congressional hearings on people
taking chemicals that aren't illegal.
They aren't legal in order to get better
at playing baseball and then a ball
with a stick. And Congress is
getting involved by the way,
while two wars going on. Yeah. The, the,
the thing that they come
down on the hardest is his
example that he sets for the
young kids who look up to him because
he's doing America's favorite pastime.
And because it's America's
favorite pastime,
there's congressional hearings
on it as opposed to cycling.
There's way more evidence of widespread
abuse of cyclers than there is of,
uh, of, of baseball players. Even though
he ends up, it's almost like all cyclists,
it seems like around something.
Oh,
did Lance Armstrong get caught or did
he get free? What happened? You know,
plea bargain, what the
legal term is? I'm not sure,
but he's had heat coming his way for
a long time as he free yet though.
I don't know, cause I, there
was some article in a magazine,
it was like the troubles behind him.
Lance Armstrong looks where I'm like,
what are you talking about? The troubles
behind him, that guy got caught.
He's caught. And what athlete isn't
looking for competitive advantage? Not Mm.
And not the combat sports. Not
Football. Not Baseball. Right.
Nascar and tennis.
Golf.
You think that they're not using
cognitive supplements? Drugs.
Who knows what it is?
Techniques. Um, artificial ways
to, you heard a selegiline.
So I have not sledge sledging into
some new cycle of mentally performance
enhancing drug.
Something that lasts like three hours.
It's like some new thing that my doctor
actually told me about it. He says it's,
it's staggering.
The newest,
the newest best thing lasts for like
three hours and it would just turns you
into a machine. I don't know man. I
haven't done it yet. I haven't done it,
but I'm scared to do it because
I'll do that shit all day. Yeah.
I wonder what like when you
mix it with weed. Hm. You know,
report because you imagine take that
shit and you mix it with weed and ball.
All of a sudden, you know, you become
like doctor Manhattan for three hours ago.
We both, I mean, I don't know,
but I know what it takes to be a champion
and the reason why you would take
those things as to recuperate anything
after 30 you're and your prime,
whatever I could understand. I mean, if,
if you're testing me at day fight
the fight day, yeah. I'm clean.
I don't get it right. If
he does, the thing is,
it's, the enhancement is not just the
enhancement inside. You know, when you,
when you, when you test clean. Okay. So
if you go to a fight, he tests clean.
It doesn't mean you've been
cleaning your whole camp.
It means you cleaned yourself up the
last few days or whatever the fuck it is
you took. As long as you're not
taking oil based things you can,
you can take testosterone up until I,
you know,
a certain amount of time before
the fight and still test normal.
And the problem with that is that you
have been able to train harder than the
other guy because you have been
unnaturally elevated and your testosterone
levels. So you've been able to do two
and three workouts a day and that's what,
there's a bunch of guys that are saying
that one of the issues with training
with so many guys getting injured is
that a lot of the guys who are getting
injured are not using,
and these are the reasons why they're
getting injured is because they're keeping
up with guys who are using and they're
trying to keep the same pace as guys who
are using and their body
is fucking breaking down
because the shit that they're
dealing with when you're dealing with a
guy that is training three times a day
and each session is at least an hour
to two hours long and they're intense
sessions and they're doing
it for six to eight weeks,
that is a lot of tissue breakdown
and a lot of that tissue,
it has to be built back up.
You know,
that's also a problem with this
performance enhancing drug argument about
testosterone replacement therapy.
Because if you catch me when I've been
up all night and I haven't gotten any
sleep and I've been working out two to
three times a day and you go in and get
your testosterone test, guess what
fuck face, it's going to be really low.
You know why it's really low
cause your body's broken down.
So if you and and and and then you
supplement the testosterone will,
that is unnatural and you also have to
realize that some guys are coming into
camp would,
there's not like one standard level of
fitness that guys are coming into camp
with.
Some guys come into camp and these are
like Hershel Walker type dudes that are
in shape all year round,
never get fat and never get out of shape.
Always disciplined,
always training.
So they have a much thicker base when
they get in their cardiovascular basis
healthier, their, their, their
muscle endurance basis healthier.
Everything is healthier so they don't,
they don't have to worry
about overtraining as much.
They can keep a pace
at the other guy can't.
But if those other guys try
to keep up with that dude,
that's when that's when
shit goes bad. So, you know,
I see the argument that you shouldn't be
allowed to be on steroids while you're,
but you shouldn't be allowed to train
on him either. You can't, he can't,
like if you're going to make them illegal,
they gotta be illegal to train with too,
because otherwise we
have an unrealistic bar.
I'm not saying that performance enhancing
hormonal supplements shouldn't be
legal,
cause I think they probably should.
They should just be closely monitored
and you've got to decide how, how,
how you want to regulate this because
eventually we're going to come up with
things that are better than this and
it's gonna. It's gonna go by the wayside.
Science is not going to stop
at testosterone replacement
or hormone replacement
or bio identical identical hormones.
They're going to have genetic engineering.
It's coming.
You're going to,
you're going to be able to
literally manipulate your
DNA. That's unquestionable.
Whether it's a hundred years from now
or whether it's 50 years from now or 20
years from now. I don't know
when it's going to take place,
but there's going to be something that
comes along and make no mistake about it.
That makes steroids obsolete.
So then the argument is going to be,
do we just say fuck science?
Do we say fuck progress?
Do we say that or do we decide
that? Well, you know what,
if you want to compete as an athlete,
you,
you can't take the stuff that
you're fucking neighbors.
The Postman is taking and the guy can
jump over buildings. You know, your, your,
your neighbor can fly through
the air like the hulk,
but you can't take that if you want to
compete and kickboxing. Yeah, it gets,
gets a little squirrely.
Absolutely. Because what
steroids are, is science. I mean,
they work,
they work.
You can't look like Lee Haney who can't
look like that without some science.
And that's a whole nother lifestyle,
let's say then. And Athlete, right?
Sure. Haney and those guys are going
on that side of the, uh, you know,
sports performance. Yeah.
That's not really an athlete.
It's like a sort of an artist with
your body, right? It's a, it is, it's,
it's a science project also.
And those guys know it.
They're trying to do things that have
never been done for full done before.
They're making new expired.
They're experimenting on themselves
with all these new chemicals and new
compounds and you know,
more size.
You remember that this synthol craze
back in the day when these dudes were
injecting you oil into
their muscles to shape out,
it was an oil that would expand,
blow up their muscle like a balloon
and it would stay and look like that.
It's crazy. And where that oil
go, it looks gross. I mean,
there were a few guys that actually
did it well, can't say names,
but are known to have done it. Some of
the most classic, you know, like, uh,
the artistic type of physique.
Just amazing, amazing things.
Didn't carrot top to that recently?
My, it looks like, I don't know,
but he's doing it. He did it or
it was photo shopped? No, no, no.
He was always yoked.
But there was like some added
ridiculousness like Brian, look up Google,
uh, Kara top Synthol, s y n t, h,
O l and I'm not hating on carrot top,
by the way. I'm never hate on that too.
I think. I think carrot top seems like
a nice guy, you know, but he, he uh,
he didn't just get swole. He got
fucking juice. It, it's 2000,
but it's not bad.
It's craziness.
It looks like it's got the loons in is
I got a fucking three biceps on top of
mine. Biceps. There's something
not fun. Right? I know. It
looks like fake tits, man.
It looks crazy. It's like balloons inside
your body. It doesn't look real all. We
just watched Tom Platz his lunch
last week, which is awesome.
Oh, I see. I see how it pops
out. Like it's not real.
It's like the implants dog.
Well, I don't think it is though.
I think you just like this guy.
Click on that guy.
That guy's a famous guy
for it. That guy, uh,
I was in contact with him on Twitter for
a little while. He's the guy that, uh,
he was on that HBO show about it.
Yeah.
Steroids, carrot tops,
steroids. That's like Jesus.
He's got a good body. It's built sexy
carrot, top carrot looking pretty sexy.
That will,
that synthol thing though.
There's a lookup synthol
dance boy synthol dances.
A guy who has a synthol tits and synthol
arms and he's like dancing around and
it doesn't even look remotely real man.
It bounces up and down.
Like he's got water balloons and his
arms and tits. It's really strange.
And he's like dancing. You know, you think
of all the people that take the juice.
Oh, it really, you know, stick
to the thing, you know the die.
How about the Yahoos of Jersey? I
mean, you worked at Montego Bay.
What about the guys down that as
you're shooting that shit, Bailey,
that taking the pills with a beer
and a wine, a blower short. I saw it.
I saw your boy, boy Danny Vega. Oh,
one time at his house on the phone.
I get what his bitch, fuck you.
You fuck.
And he's walking back and forth and all
of a sudden on top of his safe in his
safe was like money and a
thousand of those little vials.
And he would take him out
and he would cut the coat.
And while he was doing the
line, his mom would shoot up
in the end. My mom, mom, Ma,
ma, hurry up, I'm on the
phone, I'm hot, I'm cooking.
And he would fucking just pop him
in the fucking ass. And that's it.
And I knew for a fact I ran,
you know I was,
I was in Jersey in the early eighties,
when beach where I was going to ask
you if you have a shot at my boys,
but shooting mad shit.
And I used to drive my bunny to a house
where they were guys and they would
blast them with the B12, the
deck of the Roblin. You know,
those days it was Deca d
ball, uh, and Novar winstrol.
It was very basic. Five
or six of them. Sure.
And he would get to be 12 and he would
go, go, go. I suppose they shoot. Yeah,
you can taste it in your
fucking mouth. Bam, Bam.
He in mind like panties.
That's where he would taste in his mouth.
The vitamins pop right up and it was
amazing how all those guys did that even
die from Phi. He had to deliver
shit. The one, what's number two,
the hepatitis to tie this to
where you can't drink and shit,
but the rest of those
boys that were shooting,
they don't die than to have Jesus
from the 80s they didn't know.
Nobody knew back then.
They wouldn't a room going fucking look
at my biceps that bigger than yours.
Bam fucking and they were sharing needles,
sharing needles yet that you didn't know
when they need to help nobody fucking,
well, you know, bodybuilding in
and get just lifting to get big.
It's so different than doing
it for a skill and for a sport.
You know what these guys are doing as
MMA athletes is just trying to compete in
the craziest, most shark infested fucking
ocean there is as far as sports go,
fighters, professional fighters, you know,
they're just trying to
get any edge whatsoever.
The most highly conditioned athlete
in the world is the MMA athlete.
It's amazing what these guys are doing
and how it's still evolving. He'd be,
evolution is still, I
mean, what GSP, you know,
he was kind of ahead of the curve for
six years ago now. The average kid,
teenagers training like GSP
used to not that long ago. Yeah,
well then there's the Roy and Mcdonald's
is these guys who have trained in MMA
since they were boys and they don't
have a base in wrestling or bay.
There are MMA fighters from the jump,
you know, and, and when you're like,
just fully dedicated and involved like
a guy like Rory is and you're talented
and you're 21 and you're doing all the
right things and you're disciplined and
you're focused and you're
keeping your eyes and your Po,
you could see some incredible results
are possible, rounded by the right team,
right? You've got for us
and GSI out there, you know,
that kid is a beast man. And,
uh, you know, and then along once of John
Jones and I went along the lines of, uh,
you know,
Jake Ellenberger is these guys that are
new guys that are coming up and it just
fucking destroyers. You know,
that like the 170 pound division,
think about how many fucking destroyers
are in that division. You know, everybody,
it's incredible. You know, and then think
of, you know, at the same thing, one 55,
one 55, it was like, who the fuck
is next? It's like there's know,
I guess Nate is next in line for the shot,
but there's so many fucking talented
guys between Anthony Pettis and fucking
Clay Guido.
And it's like a soup of
awesome fighters and you know,
and then as Gilbert Melendez,
then Josh Thompson,
I mean those guys fucking went to war
a couple of weeks ago and that was an
incredible fight.
Gilbert is right up there with the
best in the world in my opinion.
I think he's right up there with
anybody and I think Josh has as well.
Josh look fucking
incredible in that fight.
So I think that is the one of the number
one problems with a bunch of different
organizations. I would like to get
them all fucking get them in together.
But it's like when you get like one 55,
it's like man, there's so many fighters.
It's almost impossible to get
them all fight each other.
The numbers are staggering.
Put on more events, right. Gas.
How can you pick? We were struggling
now. I mean there's a reason.
That's why I don't do the FX
or the fuel shows anymore.
It got to be just too
crazy. Sure. You know,
I do the paper views and the Fox and
then John Annex and Kenny Florian do the
other ones and then I think,
um,
Bonner's gonna do more of them and Frank
Mir I think is going to do strike force.
I've heard Frank Mir is great at it.
Mirrors really good.
It's bright and fucking
guy, man. I'm still,
I'm doing the WBC stuff years ago when
he did a great job out of the gate.
Did you ever work with him nutrition wise?
No,
I haven't spoken to him a few times.
Just the socially super cool guy.
Very intelligent, very smart
guy, knows his body, knows
the sport. No Science. Yeah.
I think people sleep on how
smart Frank Mir is for he, um,
he's judged a lot in my opinion,
by his dark days,
by the days where after the
motorcycle accident. Yeah,
of course. Of course we are.
Yeah. And he's a perfect example of a guy
who got it back together again. I mean,
people don't remember when paid it. Pano
beat him when Brennan Vera stopped him.
I mean that Frank Mir has no resemblance
to Frank Mir of today. He's a killer.
Yeah.
But even he couldn't stop that junior dos
Santos freight train who can right now.
Well, that's one of the reasons why
I wanted to see Alistair fight a man.
I think if anybody look,
Allister is, in my opinion,
the most technical striker in the fucking
heavyweight division period. Sure.
Alistair's a beast. Man, the way he throws
leg kicks, his technique is perfect.
He's strong as fuck. He's big,
you know, and that heavyweight,
he's been massively successful.
You know,
once he put all that weight on
and you know, he, he changed his,
his focus and his uh, his, uh,
his training methods and concentrate a
lot on physical strength and you know,
the technique has always been there and
it's concentrate a lot on his endurance
and really worked hard. It's unfortunate
that that fight didn't take place.
It's unfortunate that if you fall,
you mean if Allister is telling the
truth and that's exactly what happened.
A doctor fucked them. You know, a
doctor shot him up with something,
he added some inflammation and some
problems and the doctor gave him some
anti-inflammatories
mixed with testosterone,
which you know as well as
anybody will help you heal. Sure.
But you're not supposed to be doing
that, right. I mean, that's the idea,
but it's not what you're,
you're not supposed to be taking that
ever if you're a professional fighter.
Right.
That's the idea behind it.
It's not like you can take like what
happens if a professional fighter says,
I'm going to take a year
off to deal with an injury.
I got a knee and a torn knee
ligament or something like that.
Do they go and test him then while
he's recovering from his knee surgery?
Should they do?
That's a good question.
That is a good question
because a lot of doctors,
that's when they will prescribe
you steroids on a legal bay.
I know a guy who got an ACL operation
and the doctor prescribed them, Anna Var,
the doctor said this is a safe substance
to take as long as we only do it for x
amount of weeks and this
is what we're going to do.
Here's your program and this is
going to accelerate your growth, uh,
to get you back on track sooner. Or
you know, the doctor said, you elect,
when it comes to ligaments,
you really shouldn't ever try to compete
for anything quicker than six months,
six months for replacing the
ligament is like, that's, that's,
that's not even being
conservative. That's, that's like,
that's being still a little risky.
Six months is even still a little risky.
So this guy just said, but this,
this will help you, uh, put,
uh, your, your muscle back and you know,
and get you to the point where
everything is strong and it'll, uh,
it'll heal your need quicker. So that,
that becomes like a real question.
Like if you're going to say performance
enhancing drugs are illegal,
what about when a guy is
clearly not competing?
Like what about a guy that's
recovering from a knee surgery?
What do they do then? W insulin
if you're diabetic, right? Right.
That's a much more antibiotic, more
powerful hormone. And testosterone is,
is it really insulin? Absolutely. Yeah.
I mean, that's bodybuilders, you know,
they're, they're, they're
hypertrophy, um, style that weights,
that's what they're looking for.
They're looking to grow and build muscle,
get bigger,
get stronger, get leaner. UHM,
and in insulin really that,
that's the catalyst to store a or,
or for protein synthesis to build muscle
and to burn body fat. He is insulin,
dangerous to supplements. Literally
Insulin will kill you. Really.
It will kill you. But it's legal. So
talk about testosterone. Overdose,
testosterone. Yeah, he may,
you get some pimples maybe that maybe
there's some longterm effects won't
immediately kill you. Take a little
bit too much insulin. You're dead.
You're in a coma. Really hairy now.
Yeah. Yeah, that's right. Is that
the wife? She was a diabetic.
That's how he killed her.
He came in and a little shy, a little
too much insulin and you go, wow,
how much do you take
out? God, I don't know.
And it would be irresponsible to say you
should be speaking with your doctor and
have a very specific dose,
you know, cause and insulin,
something, you know, diabetics,
some blood sugar issues can certainly
be controlled by diet and lifestyle that
actually gets you off of insulin,
you know?
And that's kind of where you should be
going to, how much to take. You know,
there's guys that do some
crazy things they eat.
The more is better philosophy
as far as diet goes.
Now if you see like a
high glycemic index diet,
when you, you know, if you ate a
lot of like really sugary things,
doesn't that cause your insulin to
spike and it causes you to like fatigue
quicker?
Well it depends when you take it,
can you take it directly after a workout
when your glycogen stores are low,
then you should write and absolutely.
I,
I drink a protein drink and I eat
a banana right after I work out.
That's the one thing that I do like and
it made a big difference in how I felt
for the rest of the night.
I got to go to Jujitsu and I would wait
until I got home before I would eat.
Yeah. So it dry, you know,
I'd get in the shower,
I'd shoot the shit with
the guys at the gym,
goodnight everybody and then drive home.
It takes a half an hour almost
to drive home from the gym.
By the time I got home I was,
it was too late crash.
I was already crashing and
I didn't want to do shit.
But if I just had a protein drink,
I would bring it with me and I would
bring coconut water. I don't fill it in,
fill it, fill the, the protein
drink, you know, after,
after workout down at right away.
And it made a huge difference in how
I felt like I felt much, much better,
like physically better
for the rest of the night.
He went home 30 to 45 minutes later,
you had a well balanced meal
and you felt awesome afterwards.
That's exactly what you should be doing
when you spike the insulin right after
the workout. Even more sugar than
protein, a little bit of protein.
So you have a protein shake. It should
be more of a, you know, I like a,
a whole foods fruit
shake, you know, mixed up.
Kind of like your Kale
shake you do in the morning.
Maybe a little more sugar in there,
a little more citrus with more
barriers and more apple would have you,
pineapple spiked your incident with a
little bit of protein, banana, not enough.
Or should I just have something
instead of bananas? Bananas, good.
But you actually eat the banana?
Uh,
so it takes a little longer to break down
where you can blend it. Getting your,
so should I pour a little sugar in with
my workout drink or some Guy Gabay.
So Gavi, Gavi, bat for you. You
know, that's still on the fence.
And they say green teas bad for you.
Some people say,
everybody says everything's been,
if too much oxygen is bad for you,
you have too much love can be bad for
you. Right? Love is like oxygen. You
get too much. You get too high, not
enough, and you're going to die. Oh, hi.
Do you remember that song?
Fuck yeah. Mostly love is like
air supply. 10 CC. Ooh, remember
that sense? He's wasn't it? Oh,
I don't remember them. They did. I'm
fine. They love. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah.
I think it's demo. It could be. Who
the fuck is that? Love is like oxygen.
A sweet, sweet Jesus. Wow.
Brian, pull that shit up. Sweet.
It's from 1978 deck.
Tara's. Yeah, beginning.
Good fucking jam,
man.
You always wonder is like these guys
that made this like one or two good jams
and then it just fucking,
they couldn't keep it together.
To make sweet love is like oxygen.
It's from 1978
these motherfuckers. That was a weird
time in the world, man. You know,
as far as nutrition goes, this is like
the best time ever in human history.
Would you agree?
Well or we could reverse it a few hundred
years and maybe that was the best time,
but I mean as far as like knowledge,
knowledge, it's amazing everywhere.
I mean knowledge, you know, it's,
it's comes too fast. Technology.
Your items loudest. Is
this it? Yeah, this is,
do you remember watching rocky when he
drank the raw eggs and went running?
How bad is that for you?
It's disgusting.
We're talking about that bacteria before,
right? Yeah. Loaded full of bacteria,
but how many times did you drink
that same shake? Yeah, I did it once.
I did it right. Right after I
saw rocky, I was a little kid.
I got inspired and this or this.
Give me some volume, Brian.
Nah, nothing gone. A die. Go. Brian,
you know,
that is one of the reasons why music is
so much different than comedy because in
comedy, if a guy can pull off a
jam, if a guy could pull off a hit,
if a guy gets on stage and he's got a
bit that Nazi your fucking socks off,
that guy can keep coming
up with bits like that.
That's how that motherfucker
thinks. But not music, man.
They can nail one song and then the
rest can be just dog shit because they
worked all their life talk, travel. They
worked all their life on the first hour,
the second amount as you
leave the door. Dot. Yeah,
but it's not even the suck at first album.
Like it's a song.
It's like one or two songs,
man.
You don't know all the controlling
fucking forces. Oh yeah. The,
the just the fucking discipline involved.
I go to watch Eddie perform or Eddie
and practice and it's fucking hard work,
man. That's it. That's not what
we do, man. Musicians practice.
We fucking smoke weed and
go on the Internet and we
write things down. You know?
Well, I just learned this about
selegiline. And then you sit down,
you would a computer and you
make yourself laugh and Giggle,
and then you write down anything that
comes into your head throughout the day.
And then our practice is in front
of an audience. So our practices,
which by the way, tomorrow
night, laugh fact, where am I?
Are we going tomorrow night we're doing
another desk squad show here at the Ice
House. It's just like we, what
are we going to call them?
We're going to just desk want shows.
We need to have a name [inaudible]
death on a Wednesday night. Ice House,
bitches, Wednesday seven o'clock. Saturday
eight 30. I go up on the stage two.
I'm doing kidnap and they the Z, the
history of this. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So make a night, make a night of it, which
can go next door. She, then we have this,
two rooms were rocking tomorrow night.
Eight 30 show is Joey Diaz
is one man show. And uh,
I'm going to come watch that too. That's
at eight 30. And then right after that,
right next door at 10, that is the
uh, ice house show that we're doing.
And I'm headlining it and it starts at
10 o'clock and we got Joey Diaz is on,
Ari Shaffir is on. Brian Cowen might be
showing up. Christina Palicki who else?
Tony Hinchcliffe. Me and maybe John
had Fermin and maybe John had fun.
So these are jamming shows and we
decided Wednesday night is a good night
because almost everybody's home. You
know, most of us that go on a town,
like this weekend, I'm at the River Creek
Casino. I think it's sold out. It's,
I mean, uh, Edmonton
Alberta with the RH fear.
It may be sold out and there was
like 50 tickets left yesterday.
So if you jump on that shit dirty bitches,
but the ice house,
we haven't even announced it yet.
We're announcing it right now.
Icehouse con Oh wait a minute. I already
announced it on Twitter an hour ago.
Okay. It's announced tomorrow night.
The Wednesday night ice house.
So get on that shit.
Don't sleep.
ICEHOUSE comedy.com you can buy
tickets online and it will sell out.
We sold out last week and the week
before that and all that shit.
So we're doing them on a regular basis.
So there you go.
Joe Diaz excited about that.
Yeah, I'm more excited about it.
I got to talk to them like
they'll chase Joey Diaz.
Let's make a goal for you brother.
There's a reason why I
wanted him to confront you.
Like when you were saying you were
other fucker. Listen, I love
you. Don't know. No, no. Me.
When the guy says what are
your goals? And you like, God,
I just want to eat a little bit,
that's not a goal. Let's get a goal.
It's what's write down a goal for you.
Like a health goal.
Look when you eat, is that the
right way to do it? My culture,
but this is what I'm right with
surrounded by love right now.
Before you even go there. Okay. Three
years ago I would eat three eggs,
would have half a loaf of
wonder bread with butter,
a half a pound of bacon and potatoes.
Today when I eat eggs,
one egg, one piece of toast and two
pieces of Seneca up bacon and oatmeal.
So what I managed to do is I try to cut,
you know,
10 years ago I would eat a sandwich with
chips and the side of macaroni salad.
Now I eat a six inch with no chips and
don't macaroni salad. You follow me?
Like saying I do a little bit of coke.
So you get them.
So when I eat the pasta,
everybody always talks about right,
right there.
Is that my sprite is that you
can't spray? Yeah. Is that empty?
What's the ingredients in that
spread? Dick Water. Water, water.
Let me show you zero. It's
sprayed zero, right? Zero.
But it's got back chemicals for you.
It doesn't have bad chemicals.
I don't even see where that came with
those. We've got, what are citric acid?
Potassium citrate, naturality,
potassium benzoate. Um, aspartame.
A sole salt for mean potassium.
So,
and what do you get out of that? That's
so good. Thick. Yeah. And I mixed it up.
I got a new fucking rule at the house.
I got that thing from Costco.
Now for the last two months and I just
drink water one up at the house. Okay.
When I go out, that's my fucking treat.
God, why have you have we earned a treat?
Why? Absolutely. Tell me,
because I fucking live better.
I sleep my eight hours.
I take my fucking vitamins in the morning.
So you've achieved your goal.
You're where you want to me right now,
this is the endpoint. Not
really, but where's the endpoint?
The endpoint about to 70 okay, and how
far did we get to go had it gets too big,
but he has to deal with to my end goal
is a lot of things. What are you today?
I've been smoking this shit
lately. Well, let's back up.
What do you weigh right now to daily
eight to nine eight to seven years ago.
So 28 pounds.
How are we going to get their cut?
My intake food and what's the timeline?
Let's give ourselves a timeline.
Right now it's what may 29
six months to lose 20 pounds,
30 pounds myself. Easily obtainable.
Absolutely. Some five pounds a month,
five pounds. I could even do like eight
pounds a month if I a month. Alright.
Two pounds a week. That's pretty fucking,
that's why I think we can do that.
Two pounds a week. That's the
goal right now. Alright, great.
Way To start that is to kick that
out. No, and won't be a little bit,
that's what I've been trying to do lately
is just when I go out with friends,
like I said,
I have this insecurity.
I don't do deck now you want me to
fucking have one of these things?
I'd rather shoot myself in the fucking
it. No, no, no, no, no. That man,
that's not necessary. Come on, I'll
go to the blog and a glass of water,
but I can't do that. No, I'm
saying I, I remind with me.
I don't know what I'm saying.
I gotta do something to feel like
I'm fucking alive sometimes. Yeah.
The phone follow safety. You're hanging
out with great people. Oh No, no.
This is a lot. The Sun is
shining. You're breathing.
It's a beautiful fucking day to be alive.
You know me dog.
Every time I fucking get up. That's the
first thing I'd do is thank everybody.
There we go. You gotta be fucking
kidding me. So two pounds a week.
Now that's fine. Ways to do it. So
we've got to start making changes,
positive changes. Let me ask you some
questions about the lifting. At my age,
I like it. I liked going in there twice
a week and throw in some way to run.
It's not maximum weight. I'm doing
everything. Like you said, 12 to 15 yup.
I'm doing the bent over rows,
which I really like. One arm poles.
I do the fucking upright rows.
I do the bike to warm up every time I
go through a 45 minutes working out.
It's no problem. You like, oh, I
fucking like it. That's my thing.
So troubleshooting. If it's not,
it's is the dye apps of fuck it.
We'll circle back to the deaths of
died. Breakfast out of bed, out of bed.
You have there that one egg will have
water.
I drink six ounces of water. I drink
a cup of coffee with no sugar. Black.
Perfect. All right. And then I wait
a little while and then I go back in.
Then either let, depending on my day
have a protein shake from GNC. Okay. Oh,
I have one egg with a piece of
toast with butter on it and Bacon.
I don't like fucking milk.
I don't like almond milk cause I
looked at that thing in your book.
I don't see that's a problem I
had with the book but not really.
I even asked Joel Bach, we know
we had out. He was fucking,
the reason why he's saying it quick
keen was a weird spelling. It's Q. U. I.
A sesame street. You don't
have to fucking say no, no, no.
A lot of people don't know. People
are asking me and they spell it crazy.
Keen wide sounds like k. E.
N w or something like that.
How do you spell it, man? Q. U.
I. N. E. A. S. Yeah, there we go.
Yeah, it's, it's, it's acute fucks me up.
I looked in the thesaurus and everything
but I want to have you tried it.
It looks like he looks like Joseph comes
in bags and sometimes he eats it with a
steak and he's going to fucking
hate it. So I'll try. I'll try.
It's what you mix it with.
Don't eat it by itself.
What are you going to make it with?
I don't know how to look at the fucking
book and see what you got of cheese,
if that's what we gotta do to get you out
saw sauce. What the fuck dog? Perfect.
You get me some Goddamn fucking hippie
food it tastes like so, wait a second.
Let's get something straight. Let's get
fucking something straight right here.
I love this. You know I live, listen,
I got to do something that
a lot of people didn't do.
Joe Rogan and watchman is he,
he wasn't there for it.
I grew up in Jersey where there's
great food in New York City.
I lived in San Francisco.
We go to Texas,
which is the best fucking restaurants
or the country, Texas. We go to Vegas,
but the fucking restaurant that always
got my debit card was in boulder.
Colorado was called the
harvest restaurant on Canyon.
But I'm Pearl Street and because
they had everything vegetarian,
you're looking at me going Joey,
I don't see it.
They had a vegetarian Gazpacho that your
asshole would fucking quake the whole
way home. I couldn't
wait to taste it. Nice.
I a Swiss harvest Granola for
breakfast. I ate eggs. I hate eggs.
But the breakfast bowl you got
is kind of fucked up for me.
So that's something
that everybody loves it.
There's something that I don't like egg
whites either. You got to put some money.
I don't have any,
there was something in the breakfast and
just the whole buckwheat and that shit
that the bus, uh, gluten
free. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Joey,
the reason why I can in front of you
and the reason why I talked about it
earlier and when I, when I keep
getting onto the point of, you know,
you having a goal is cause I know
you've done it before. You know,
I was really proud of you when you quit
smoking and I was really proud of you
when you lost all that weight in minutes.
Pretty impressive for a guy who in my
life you've been a real impulsive sort of
wild dude, you know? I mean,
you've always, when you want to,
you have control, but
sometimes you, like you say,
you give yourselves rewards that like
Mike said, you haven't earned. I know,
and that's that's it's an impulsive thing.
It's part of being a great comic.
It's that I don't give a fuck attitude.
I'm going to do whatever the
fuck fucking bed at 7:00 AM.
I'm walking my fucking wife to
the tray. Right? What were ward,
aren't you fucking talking
about Robert Water, you people?
How many people have told you I want
to Holler, willing Noni fucking reward.
The reward is I work every
fucking day. I had the surgery
and I had to sit at home,
so at that time I had a fucking,
they told me to go to the fucking gym,
have bulk up. I got this fucking
Cuban body that when I touch away,
I told you to bulk up,
do the fucking squat and all
that shit made towards quiet,
get my metabolism going. I got a
whack off. I've got a bank, the wife,
I go fucking bananas.
Then I went and got that GNC fucking
protein powder and I added it on there.
But for fuck, I kept the weight off. I
was at two 80 whatever. I'm feeling good.
My blood pressure down on my fish,
the basically yelled and backed us into
a corner because you know back up are
you fucking talking about there's
no reality count when you're on yet.
I work out every fucking day. That's what
I'm telling you. Why every fucking day.
But what he's saying is when you drink
sprite zero though fucking points one
spot.
Watch things on top of the shit issue.
I'm on the board
versus your book to enhance what I was
doing. Let me, I love wait, watch TV.
And then I love weight watchers. So
when you use the in the calorie concept,
the calorie count is wrong because the
donor has a hundred calories in it and a
chicken breast or six boys who are six
or you use the weight watchers points.
That doesn't mean you're healthy.
What's your nutrient quality?
Let's talk about yourselves.
How do your sales look?
Cause really we're just big blobs of
sales were billions and billions of cells,
which the health of ourselves, the way you
look, your physical presence right now,
that you're just a combination of
sales and how healthy are these sales.
And that's based upon the nutrient
quality of what it's taking.
And also external sign,
you know,
factors of an environment and then
your relationships, things like that.
But yourself.
So nutrient quality,
you're talking about points points mean
nothing because it's just a calorie
structure, which is wrong. You
burn calories, you know, you know,
moving around throughout the day, your
calorie expenditure changes dramatically.
You know, you're sitting in
traffic. Use that example.
You're sitting in traffic for two hours,
bumper to bumper,
you're stuck or you cruise home,
he's at two totally different days.
You have two totally different
nutritional needs. So speaking with you,
we need to focus on nutrient
density on nutrient.
And that's not nutrient density.
That's garbage.
That's a bunch of chemicals on it. Yeah,
but that's just, that's no calories.
That's one step. That's one little button
and got sodium in our retains water.
Thousands of weather.
But small decisions.
You can't live like a fucking priest
all the time. So don't equate.
Equate Soda Not Drinking Soda Free.
What would you rather that we have?
Get them like diary queen. Get them.
Mike, would you rather me have this?
You know what he's doing? Dairy
Queen. Do you follow him saying no,
I'd rather have you,
you have some black coffee if you need
something special but a little coffee guy.
Have some tea. Make water, make a
tea at home. Make something special.
Make your own citrus cues, bringing
it with and get it locally. I mean,
you can walk out this door right
now. I don't like fucking costs. So,
but you know the, the place Joe into the,
the lovebirds. I'm just cafe and Megan.
I'm sure they have something
good there. Well, we were here.
I'm not going to fuck a walk around.
We're here now.
You're not going to work three
minutes to have something healthy.
You're going to stay where
you are to have something unhealthy.
That is where the spiral begins.
So now you're queuing negative
instead of skewing positive.
I was happy to see you.
I wasn't going to excuse myself.
I would always here with you.
It's a fucking water.
I would have walked with
you down there on my back.
If I have to say to bring you then Joey
and aid where you are, his daughter, me,
you, he'll start smiling. We
love you. Love me from reality.
You guys don't understand this hill was
my reality because he don't know if this
fucking guy, when it comes to
this shit, he doesn't know. Dig.
My reality was mother fucker.
I know you bought in,
you know you and I woke up in
the morning after I do coke.
If I had a piece of Sushi,
that was my workout for the day.
I thought in the back of my mind that
Sushi would cleanse the cocaine out of my
life. I actually believe that if you
drank pomegranate juice, wheat grass,
I could go out and do blow today.
So this is the guy you're talking to
about this shit. So now I'm telling you,
you're a new guy. The old guy,
Joe Rogan. What's my rule?
What's my fucking rule about the road?
I don't want to be on a fucking
note show on a Sunday night.
And there's reasons because on Sundays I
go to the farmer's market every fucking
week and I buy fruit. I Buy
Bananas. I throw him in my
fucking the protein shakes.
I try. You know what? I drink. I drink.
This is what was going on when you guys
do is shut the Sunday show in Cleveland.
No, we used to fuck
that. I was backed by no,
fuck
that.
Fuck that part of the,
you should know. Hi Julie.
We want to book you on a Sunday night.
Unless you're paying the freight.
I can't do it because you're
knocking me out of my week.
That the fuck Outta here. We
got to, you got gotta farmers,
but 10 years ago if I went to a
restaurant, I thought that was healthy.
Mike before the book,
you don't know how nice it is in
the morning to make one egg and no,
you're not even home fries and a bunch
of disgusting butter from a stuck in the
diner. I grew up in Jersey.
He meets his brother.
So now I try to plan my Mr Diner
sometimes too. Oh and open steak sandwich,
a gravy on the French
cheese burger cheese.
But every time I of the charities, every
time I go to jersey, I say that myself.
I'm going to get a cheeseburger
deluxe and I don't.
So when I'm in Jersey with Johny
Hendricks on this last, uh, Fox card,
I'm home every single day.
I had a jersey Friday disco fries,
French fries and gravy.
No out every day.
And port grow and cheats.
Oh, you know what I mean?
So there's my earned meals because I've
been grinding for so long and I may,
I'm going home, I'm going in jersey,
I'm eating like a crazy motherfucker.
And that's exactly what I did.
I built that up and I worked towards
it and I knew six weeks beforehand I'm
going to do it. You're going to do, we
believe in a cheat days, cheat meals,
and I use the cheat meals,
earned meals because cheating
has a negative connotation. It's,
I'm going to earn this,
I'm an this and I plan.
And then seven weeks I'll be back
in Jersey, one of the pizza place.
But you know what I mean?
We work at Harbin and run farther.
I'm going to eat better. I'm going to do
more things so I can have that. The, the
investment in myself where I can go out
there and do a little bit more and feel
good and have that emotional purge. No,
we can put you on the map. My gold chain.
Let's get Joey Diaz healthy. Can
we get, Joey has really helped me.
I'm going to say we've already started
that. Michael Chang we started today.
You're showing them is not
taking any of his bullshit.
He's screaming and yelling. I love it.
I'm going to send you a tape every week.
That's how I'm doing it from marijuana.
But my man,
Mike don't checks were in the middle of
a podcast and Joey's just pull out a kid.
The video podcasts. It's not
filming. It's not filming.
Brian's a wizard.
You can't trick Brian Trick
Brian with some technology. No,
I'm not saying it wasn't on purpose,
but you can't. You know, you see,
you know when the fucking thing
is working. Joey has no idea.
I don't fucking video. It was like
that bad flavor here with my boys,
Joe Rogan making video,
dolce and red band.
They put me on the dolce
challenge. How many pounds? Torque?
30 30 pounds. The goal is to
make your head look too big,
but it's really about being healthy.
So every week I'm going to make a little
youtube video Mike and show them that
I'm working on. Yes. Beautiful. Yes. A
week. Two pounds a week. We started it.
We started it right here. Revolution.
Yup. That's shit. That's by the way.
Two pounds. What the fuck, dog? Why
are you busting my balls? Listen folks,
you could,
you could give Joey some love
and encouragement tomorrow
night at the Ice House.
10:00 PM show. I don't even
know. Fucking love it. Love it.
Needs Encouragement and the end.
Then there's an eight 30 show Joey's doing
in the second room. It's a small room.
The second room only has 85 seats.
It's a real smoke. Six Five,
seven seven 1894 call now and then the
fucking suspects or go to the ice house
comedy.com and follow them on Twitter,
ice house,
cc.com and also followed the dolce diet,
the d o l c e Diet.
If you don't,
if you don't know how to spell diet,
go fuck yourself.
Um,
uh,
thank you everybody for tuning into
this podcast tech. You, Marc Dolce.
They was fucking brilliant time.
Thank you Joey. We loved, sorry.
We had to confront you it out of love.
You know,
I do what I love have had an opportunity
to grab you and hold you down and Mike
Dolce helped me out.
I'm going to get you in the right back.
You guys were going to get you in
the right motion right now, man.
I'm gonna have him. Thank you
for being here, man. Anytime man,
you know your family and uh,
thank you everybody for tuning in
and thank you to the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net. Click on the link
unless Joe Rogan show bitches squad.
Mike Dolce is the official nutritional
provider for desk squad. Yeah, official.
He's an official nutritious
cause. He answers. Yes he does.
And your book is, it's the dolce
diet living lean to the delta,
that.com it's on kindle and all that
good stuff. Beautiful. So it's on,
you can get it on Amazon. It's a
good, it's a good book. Oh yeah.
Beautiful Fuck around. Oh,
nice. Beautiful. All right,
so please support Mike Doyle Chang. Go,
go, go get that book. You dirty bitches.
And um, thank you everybody. Thanks to the
fleshlight. Thank you to.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech sport shroom tech.
I'm immune and new mood and hemp protein
powders come and suit and you're going
to love it.
It's the best tasting shit of all time.
We'll see you tomorrow with the great
bobcat. Goldthwait oh my goodness.
Brian might have a
little Geek boner shakes.
It's one more guy that hates Jay Moore.
All right.
Okay.